They call me Alan because I'd be awake.
I'm not awake.
I'm so sleepy.
Suppressing Yon.
Suppression successful.
No, now I'm thinking it.
Alan wake!
Alan wake, Alan woke, and then Alan walked, and Alan ran,
and Alan did a bunch of things, actually.
Don't say John Wick!
Don't do it!
Wait, did it just start the intro again?
Whatever, it's fine.
That wasn't me yawning, that was me silently yelling.
I hope you're feeling a bit better.
I'm sorry, my very...
I'm okay.
I'm sorry, my very first playthrough of MGS today.
I beat Psycho Mantis.
Excited to start playing more.
Yeah!
Also, Mambo, thank you so much for the 10 gifts.
Thank you!
Psycho Mantis fight is always, like, such a good...
A good...
Like, you know?
And then...
You know?
And then also...
you know we have to thank you for the podcast
I'm watching the new John John no John who John
don't say John no I had a dream about a VTuber donuts collab
but I didn't get to eat one so now I'm going to go get one
for real what's up with all the donuts We're donuts lately.
Donuts lately.
Thank you.
Dispatch, right?
Joy, y'all.
No, this is Alan.
This is Alan.
I'm drinking coffee right now.
I did not sleep well.
So I'm a little sleepy.
I need to Alan wake up for real.
Holy cow.
Oh my gosh, I need to Alan wake up.
No, no Alan sweep.
No sweep.
Wait, Alan sweep.
Alan wake up and Alan do the thing.
I have to remember how to play this game too.
Just a heads up for everybody.
I'm feeling a little icky.
A little under the water today.
But we do our best.
We do our besties.
Um...
So I'm just gonna get into it because, um...
What time am I streaming with Doki?
Oh, yeah, I remember.
I remember.
I have lots of time.
Let's keep playing.
I love that.
Your health will slowly recharge.
If you can avoid...
Take a damage.
Worst weather I've ever seen.
You should put some coffee on.
It'll warm you up.
That's him.
I'm Alan Wake, I'm Alan.
Wait, coffee!
Oh my gosh, wait, I forgot!
That's really what we were here for.
Whoa, my goodness, the weather.
Also...
What is this castle my man is living in?
Hello?
Why are we in this...
What is this place?
Do we live at Hogwarts?
For real!
Oh my, what's this?
We got a new TV?
It's a CC!
Wow, those are really good.
See?
Wait, that looks like a Metal Gear font, no?
A little bit?
Dang.
Kind of.
A little bit.
I thought we were in New York, but like Oh my goodness, how
conceit.
Hey handsome.
This is going to be a long night, but these shots are
turning out great.
I guess you're going to need that coffee then.
I'll go put it on.
Oh, we got the Tharmos.
Oh yeah.
Look at that.
Wait, these look like actual photographs.
These are renders from the game.
That looks like a real man.
Also, what is going on here?
Alan, thank you so much for the fun.
Get the dick.
Thank you!
The real!
That's the actor!
Wait, are these real?
Wait, I'm climbing up the stairs.
Alan climb?
Wait, what are you doing up there?
Oh my god!
What are you doing up here?
Alan, don't do it!
Hello wife!
Okay, okay.
I have to remember how to play, but I forget that we can
only go into like combat mode when the spooky things are
happening.
Why is there a QR code on the wall?
Wait, what am I examining?
I'm examining this, but not the QR code?
If I didn't know any better, I would think that the book
series was called Alan Wake.
an Casey thriller why is your name so big then right like
okay hold on I'm gonna scan this there's my phone right here
I'm gonna scan it also I hear a radio but I don't know where
it's coming from I see YouTube what is this vision 2 what is
this.
Vision's carried by the ebb and flow of different dream
states.
I see tin from the reality beyond.
He's riding.
Wait, hold on.
Let's get away from the radio because it's annoying.
The radio sound is annoying.
Is it in here?
Oh, it must be.
Oh, yes, let's turn this off.
Please.
Or turn on.
Oh, or turn on.
Overcompensation for internal frailty.
Wow, wait.
Oh, it didn't make their side of the bed.
Okay, let me watch this video.
It's only a minute long.
Also things I couldn't possibly know.
I used them in my writing.
Can you hear it?
So that the parts that weren't would become so.
And there were visions that I knew were not real.
Ideas I had lost.
He's just at a typewriter.
I had written about him for years.
I used them as well.
The lies had to feel true for them to become true.
Had I always written this way?
Even before.
Seen things without realizing I was seeing them.
Was I really always this bad at writing?
Was this what inspiration was for me?
Wait, I missed Vision 1 then.
That's so sad.
Okay.
Good job.
You can do it.
You can do it, Alan.
Alex Casey is literally legally distinct Max Payne.
Can I go in the closet?
Oh, shoot, I can.
Can I leave the closet?
It swings both ways.
Wow, that is a small washing machine.
Why is it in your bathroom?
Okay.
Can we take a shower?
We're not stinky enough.
A candle in the bathroom.
Ooh!
Wow, this is a really nice bathroom, though.
Yeah, it's a little...
There's another candle.
I don't know if that one needs to be there.
Both of their toothbrushes in one cup.
Okay.
All right, let's go switch on the coffee maker for real now.
What is this?
Is that like decor?
Oh, no, that's a flashlight.
Uh-oh.
Am I going to have to be doing like fuse puzzles in this
game?
Oh, my God.
What's that?
Parliament?
Oh.
Building maintenance will need access to your...
unit between 9 and 9 45 a.m.
this coming Thursday to replace the filters in the air ducts
okay old building someone clean they licked their bowl clean
there's a nope wait that's a blender or is that a coffee
wait oh that's a coffee's on If I'm gonna finish this by
tomorrow.
Yep.
Oh, hey.
I just finished those cover mock-ups.
They're on your desk.
Tell me what you think.
No kidding.
I didn't think you'd get them done this quickly.
On occasion, I can perform all sorts of miracles, my dear.
That was the audio, by the way.
Just let me know.
Oh, yeah, I saw these.
Wait, he puts himself on the cover also?
Is this about...
Is this an autobiography or...
These look really good.
Oh, sure, until Barry gets his hands on them.
Which, by the way, will happen over my dead body.
These look really good.
The last time was the last time.
Oh, and speaking of Barry, he called.
Alan, please check the fuse box.
Are you okay?
I'm right here.
I'm on it, honey.
Okay.
Please hurry.
It's right here, right?
I'm right here, baby.
Yeah.
I'm fine.
Just get the lights back on.
Now, please.
Oh, it's a power outage.
Oh, I've got the flashlight.
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
We've got the flashlight.
got we've got the flashlight i can't i can't equip it yet so
hi hi i'm sorry i just it just really spooked me don't worry
we'll just break out the candles oh i know the mood but it's
just oh my god the mood especially when i'm not prepared for
it you know okay it gets to me i love you i love What's
happening?
I used to have these nightmares when I was a kid.
The dark really spooked me too.
They like talk over each other.
It's so funny.
My mom gave me this old light switch.
She called it the clicker.
The clicker, huh?
The clicker?
If I ever got scared of the dark, I could just flip the
switch and a magic light would scare the monsters away.
Oh, sure.
That's what I do in the game.
Here it is.
The clicker.
Maybe it'll help you too.
Yeah, a nice story writer, boy.
Why is he shaking?
He made that up right now, didn't he?
No, no.
Seriously.
is that that's not a view oh even if you are a liar thanks
for this
oh my god the candles they lit a lot of candles wow are they
the only place that lost power i think we're cursed bright
falls the present day okay so how do you feel mr wick any
nausea like that mr.
Wake how you feel let me answer doc oh my god I'm okay my
head's fine I had to lie about my headache and memory loss
he'd send me to a hospital for tests I couldn't leave
without Alice hmm very well the fish I don't think you have
a concussion but you've obviously been through quite a shock
you should take it easy for a couple of days mr.
Wick no way did he say Wick no way he said wick oh it does
sound like it pain gets any worse or you experience any
other symptoms you should come see me I'll let you get on
with it then Sarah sheriff breaker is waiting for you she's
very good at her job I'm sure she can locate your wife in no
time Doc Nelson was the image of a small town doctor sheriff
breaker had called him to the station to take a look at the
cut in my head what if this is like one big like it's it's
one big gaslight there that Alan sorry Alan wake please sir
I must examine this fish I'm sorry you had to cut your
morning fishing shore for this he just brought it in not the
biggest I What if Alan Wick, Wick, and John Wick are
connected, but I'm just being gaslit.
If you prefer a lure, now if you want either trout or salmon
on the other hand, then it's fly fishing for you.
Um, you a fishing man, Mr. Wick?
Game audio is low.
I think it's just they're talking, but I'll turn it up.
But it can be very relaxing out there.
You can't get me off the water this time of year.
I'll take your word for it, Doc.
Okay, Doc.
He's all in on them fish.
It's a conspiracy.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
Oh, cause a mess.
Knock it over.
Come on, Alan.
Alan destroyed.
He's like a Pokemon in my brain.
What is this?
What?
This takes place in the 80s, right?
Or 70s?
You're good to go, Mr. Wake.
Sarah's probably waiting for you.
a chance to talk to you okay i'm working on it
oh it's modern day wait why did i think it was so early then
just the calendar was old oh okay i see nothing else oh
who's messing with the lights is that you thank you for
testing the lights miss weaver everything seems to be fine i
don't have
Okay, well maybe don't have them.
Missing people.
Have you seen these men?
Richard Bao, Bruce Dansky, Jacob Miller.
Are these devs?
No, no, Sparatu.
Just, just lie to yourself.
Ryan Reynolds, wait.
Wait, do you think we do that?
Just lie to you about Ryan Reynolds for over here?
No?
On a camping trip, over here.
do haven't been in contact if you have seen them or know
their whereabouts please call 555-9932 thank you is this the
dev have you seen this man disappeared uh june 20th 2007
identifying features knack for winning contest a cat wait i
can't read the cat sign lame okay this is sarah's office
more breaker stuff okay my name is ibu wisp and i'm a minter
is that a it looks like an out yep ambulance um i came from
in here what's in here nothing oh the lady's gone wake the
sheriff is waiting for you in her office down the corridor
okay but do you have like a thermos in here that was cynthia
weaver i guess you can call of the town eccentric she used
to be the editor of the local newspaper but she's focused on
um all other things these days okay fit right in where i
come from as you can see she's a little obsessed with
maintaining the light bulbs of the whole town refuses to
step on shadows things like that just spilling the tea i
didn't even ask sorts of weird things in the paper bright
falls has a colorful history of course what small town
hasn't right literally just spilling all her business when I
didn't you just want to gossip what is the cell area like
for phones sheriff wants to see you in her office mr.
wake okay hold on I'm exploring and taking your thermos
thank you oh what's this oh manuscript nice oh that's right
I need to read these I got the other one earlier too
nightmare okay Oh, prison cells!
Oh!
Uh, okay, wait, this isn't, um, no, we're on episode two.
The Sudden Stop?
Oh wait, when did I get a third one?
It's true what they say about the fall and the sudden stop
at the end.
I'd lain here in the snow while the lurid chain of scenes
that had led me here kept playing in my head.
A rerun of my own private snuff movie.
A memory of my corpse.
Alone at my own wake Alan Wake Metaphors again The femme
fatale was gone Fatale Only a sour taste remained of the
kiss That smacks Pansby I was gonna say he sounds so like So
Um This was a late goodbye 13 years after I'd gotten my
revenge It had finally caught up with me It had been a long
time to bear the pain My blood hit the snow red a gruesome
oh my god is this he's about to die painkillers and
leisurely dripped down to the sewer mingling with the bile
of the city becoming one with it ew i can see them now my
wife and my baby honey i'm home my wife and my baby my wife
and my baby alice looked through the viewfinder lining the
shot cauldron lake was breathtaking something caught her eye
a figure standing in the shadows behind the cabin oh like a
thin woman in a black dress that's the lady we saw camera
and looked again no one there just a collection of bushes
that looked vaguely human shaped she shook her head and
laughed oh wow there's a lot of pages this time okay alan
writes crime fiction novels that was the voice of the
protagonist yeah that's what I figured.
Oh, wait.
Uh, examine.
Yeah, it's Mulligan here.
I'm at Stucky's gas station with Thornton.
There's no sign of him.
Oh, they're still looking for Stucky.
Wait, wait, wait.
Yeah, this is Thornton.
Look, we've located the gray float.
It's here.
That's some goodness, right?
Stucky was supposed to be driving it at the rehearsal today.
Over.
Oh, give me that.
Well, we saw someone else driving it.
Looks like someone really fresh.
The garage.
Over.
That wasn't me.
Roger that, guys.
Keep looking for Stucky.
That guy's long gone.
That guy is dead, dead, dead.
Wait, so if they die possessed, do they die in real life?
I guess so.
I wanted to see what the other side of that was, but...
Oh, well.
Okay.
Sheriff Breaker is waiting for you down the corridor in her
office.
I'm going, I'm going.
Triple dead.
Dead, dead, dead.
Your phone's on the desk.
The battery was dead.
It's charged now.
Thank you.
have you started looking for my wife yet my men are already
on it now can you tell me what happened i'm not sure they're
like yelling at each other all of a sudden we were arguing i
walked out of the cabin the cabin on cauldron lake yes how
did you end up at stuckey's gas station i wanted to tell her
what had happened last night but i couldn't she'd lock me up
excuse me i need to take this We're like part of an
investigation now.
Alice, please help me.
Alice?
Stop talking to the law.
You'll do exactly what I say if you ever want to see your
wife again.
Who is this?
Go to the back lot.
There's a hole in the fence on the left.
Look inside the junker.
I left a little something there to convince you we're all on
the same page here.
After you ditched the cops, you're going to meet me in
Elderwood National Park.
There's a spot called Lover's Peak.
Lover's Peak.
Don't do nothing stupid, pal.
Mr. Wake, can I help you with anything?
I need to get some air.
said i could go out back i couldn't go anywhere yet i had to
play along with the caller wait everybody's talking at once
wait why are there three people talking at once oh my god
please shut up what is that where am i oh this way he went
on a bender and beat danny pretty badly he started shouting
like that the moment he woke up shut up thank you hey you're
all right shut up good guy don't let anybody tell you
different you know i shouldn't even be in here yeah the cops
they got it all wrong yeah i got it sure sure i beat him up
i wasn't drunk no i mean i wasn't drunk at the time i only
got drunk is this a yapping game holy cow okay listen oh he
really he's the yapper wait what's in here oh a manuscript
It wasn't Danny?
Wait, is he also fighting?
These cells are humongous.
It was a goddamn space alien!
I know it sounds like something that a drunk would say, but
believe me.
I wasn't drunk then.
I believe him.
Oh.
okay bye the early morning light hurt my eyes and made me a
headache the man on the phone had said go through the fence
on the left okay wait one second I have to read my
manuscript the dark presence at the diner I mean though I'll
be on a great day you too Quinn thank you thank you
it found the one spot in the diner that was dark enough some
light spilled into the corridor ravaging it but it took the
pain horrible as it was the writer would soon fix that he
would be coming to the one place where it still had power
what this makes what what what does that mean oh thermos
thank goodness what's what's what's going on here well folks
it's been another long night and uh it's about time for me
to sign off for a while god knows i need my beauty sleep
you're going to sleep at like 8 a.m just one more item
before a busy night she's a rider we've had a few broken
windows even a report is shots fired on mainstay shots fired
oligan and thornton had to deal with two intoxicated young
men who were celebrating the completion of their deer fest
float now folks we get this every year i know it's exciting
the big Let's save it for the party And leave the gunplay
for the shooting competition There's no point in getting all
worked up yet Alright Oh
My last stream got struck For the music The caller had told
me to find a hole in the fence Behind the police station
There was something for me in an abandoned car Oh I see a
manuscript even Wait one second I'm exploring I'm exploring
please Please understand I'm Do you think they could see me?
That sounds about right.
Yeah, that's okay, though.
I'm exploring, I'm exploring.
All right, a hole in the fence.
Hole, uh, probably.
Um, yeah, yeah.
Where could a hole?
If I were a hole, uh, it sounds like the opening song for
what's it called for um what we do in the shadows you're
dead you're dead you can't jump right oh yes i can i'm an
idiot all right alan kick oh that was it alan kick i sure
hope nobody heard that oh my gosh okay did he leave my
manuscript i don't think so What is, where are we anyway?
What is this?
I'll just pull that right now.
Just kidding, I won't.
Alice's driver's license had been placed on the front seat.
Oh, it was.
The caller meant business.
Uh-oh.
Mushy, mushy.
Barry?
Ow, ow, thank God.
Where the hell have you been?
I've been trying to reach you for a week.
You and Alice.
I've been worried sick.
I flew out yesterday.
Barry!
I'm at the sheriff's station.
Come and get me.
I can't talk now.
Ow!
What the hell is going on?
What are these berries?
You think we can eat them?
I needed to get to Elderwood National Park to meet Alice's
kidnappers.
Exit the sheriff's station.
I mean, I could just jump over the fence, right?
Let's just try that.
Wait.
Come on, Alan, jump!
Alan, parkour!
That'd be cool, we're taking so much for the five kisses!
I know we can pull this.
Come on, come on, game.
Let me sequence break a little.
These berries, whatever they are, look delicious.
That's how...
That's, you know, I'm just following primal instinct.
He's afraid of fences, probably.
Are you okay?
You asleep?
Oh!
a writer is alike that reveals the world of his story
through darkness you shut up shapes it from nothingness the
way a sculptor carves a statue from a block of granite if i
stop the world i'm making dies darkness will reclaim it it's
a long hard journey into the dark alice's life is at stake
but i can't think about that or i'll lose it the dread
lingers at the edge of perception i'll push on anything is
possible here i'll write the story i'll save her
Oh.
Uh-oh.
You good, buddy?
You need that CPAP machine?
Oh, boy.
I'm gonna turn off the lights for him.
I just wanted to settle all the damage the Anderson brothers
might have inadvertently caused on their recent and
regrettable little outing.
They are not accountable for their actions.
Of course, I can assure you that my staff has been
reprimanded.
Odin never caused any trouble to anyone when they were still
living at their farm indeed all we can do is to slow down
the progress of their dementia can you do that oh are you
feeling any better mr.
wake I'd like to leave am I free to go well we still need to
talk about under arrest oh no that's always so suspicious
you know I need to know where you'd be staying so I can get
in touch with you I'd avoid the motel the majestic is known
for its roaches the cabins at elderwood are pretty nice oh
that sounds perfect i'm dr emil hartman i'd like to invite
you to stay at coldren lake lodge did you talk to my wife i
had the pleasure of discussing your situation with her on
several occasions oh wait this is the guy right that she was
like her here my clinic is a place where oh that's right
where she was like hey you need to go to the clinic so ride
again nobody move get your hands off of my client who are
you i'm barry wheeler his agent i'm barry wheeler you talk
to me you yokeles won't know what hit you once i sick my
lawyers on your asses no harm done sarah i'm all right i
don't want to press charges i'm barry wheeler my uncle of
joey wheeler get me out of here what the hell was that about
ow We don't need a replay of that thing with the paparazzi.
I thought they were gonna lock you up.
Whoa, watch out for cars.
The goat, the goat.
I've had to talk to someone.
I told Barry everything.
He thought I was certifiable.
But when he heard about the manuscript, I had him.
The fact that I'd written something, even if I couldn't
remember it, was enough for him.
He smelled money.
That is maybe evidence, right?
Money?
And he believed that Alice had been kidnapped.
Anything beyond that was another story.
I had a midnight appointment with the kidnapper in a place
called Lovers' peak somewhere in elderwood national park the
plan was to rent a cabin i don't like it al i don't like any
of it it's not good in fact it's the absolute opposite of
good mr wake oh no it's rose again oh wow i was just
thinking about you too great i was just bringing he's so
mean he's on the balcony looking after max poor thing i
really need to go great to see you again mr wake later Bye!
Who's Max?
What an airhead.
Max Payne?
Jeez, Mr. Takes a swing at everybody.
This is not her fault.
She's a very nice girl and, more importantly, a fan.
Okay, okay.
You didn't tell me.
They were like, wow!
The skeleton of a Colombian mammoth.
submitted to be 14,000 years old was recovered from the La
Brea Tar Pits in 1981.
It was donated to the Elderwood National Park in 1998 when
the Colombian mammoth became the, became Washington state
fossil named Bucktooth Charlie since, it has since become
the park's official mascot.
Oh, you know, there's a, there's a, there's a, like a,
what's it called, a fossil, my brain today there's a fossil
like cast what do you call them but it's right outside the
dinosaur ride at Disney and her name is Sue she's one of the
versions of Sue but she's the only one that's in motion like
all the other ones are kind of just standing there she's a
T-Rex and yeah mold you know what you know and uh And hers
is the only one.
The only one that's in motion is the one outside of dinosaur
in the animal kingdom.
Sue the original used to be in Chicago.
Yeah, there's a couple Sue's now.
She out and about.
Look at them bears.
Whoa.
Wait.
That's their, that's its foot, right?
Looking mighty serious.
What's this?
Oh my god.
It's so cute.
I want a plush.
Wait, I want a Charlie plush.
What's over here?
Oh.
Hold on.
I need a closer look.
Wow.
Look at that.
Seriously, Al.
What you were saying in the car, just listen to yourself.
Hold on.
his body just disappeared what was the last time you slept
what are you high no you've been drinking no no look Barry
I'm missing a week and someone's got Alice do you understand
what it sounds like when you say just talk of yeah but when
you start confusing fiction with reality you're buying
yourself a ticket to the funny farm wait here okay hold on
I'm exploring I didn't know we were in a museum okay i'm
very excited right now no please i mean i want to see every
exhibit what else we got here ice age exhibit eclipse
cuisine insomnia relief fund alan interrupt what do we got
here dear nuisances every one of them oh my god i thought
this was gonna be like about the deer no they suck says that
person majestic creatures oh okay so the cougars are called
majestic and the deer are called nuisances deer are terrible
they're so cute though i watch a live cam of a deer trough
and they just come up and they're just like chomping down
and sometimes they kick each other are deer territorial i
don't really know much about them this is discrimination
against deer i agree they can be deer are just jerks i mean
it's really bad if you hit a deer because usually you will
be getting more damage to your car and yourself than them.
Thanks to their museum and animatronic yaps, Minto.
This is a great birthday stream!
Best, best, happy birthday!
What else do you want to...
Here, I'll read the rest of it for you.
Alan, jump.
Alan, I can't jump.
I can't jump.
It won't let me.
That's a door I go, thank you.
This one, this looks like a kiwi.
Kind of making me hungry.
Alright, we'll keep going.
Look at that bear.
Look at the size of that guy.
Oh, grizzly bear!
It happened while I was fishing at my usual spot.
I guess you could say the deer aren't very dear to the
museum.
I'd stayed out later than I meant to.
Sun was already going down.
Suddenly this huge animal...
Oh!
We have a dog?
Oh, no.
Oh, thermos.
Nothing happens to the dog, does it?
Please tell me now.
Dog.
Well...
Why are you guys smiling?
It's not a smiling thing.
You should be frowning.
It should be sad.
Whoa.
Easy there, boy.
I'm almost done.
Are you okay?
rusty right you rent cabins oh mr.
Wake I'd shake your hand but mine are kind of full here
actually I'm sorry about this would you mind grabbing the
registration form from the desk it's just across from
Bucktooth Charlie okay sure what happened yeah crazy
poachers max here got his foot caught in a trap they're
illegal to use here hell you're not supposed to hunt within
the park at all but that doesn't stop some low lives I'll
kill her is gonna be okay you got lucky oh max is still
groggy from the shot I gave him and I'd rather not leave him
alone just yet you can't just go and meet a kid no
situations always end up in disaster you gotta talk to the
cops hold on my wife and it's my call can we talk about this
later no this whole thing listen you hit your head I mean
geez Al come on you got to understand how crazy all this
sounds if you're trying to pull a joke on me freak me out
it's working ha ha let's have a laugh on Barry well you had
me go in there real funny Al you can quit it now awkward
there's the four oh we gave him to the dog and here are the
keys okay you're all set mr.
wake glad to have you staying here thank you can you tell me
how to get to lover's peak oh sure it's at the end of the
nature trail okay just follow the paths you'll get to it
eventually it's an easy walk okay nice spot too oh is it dog
okay if you have any trouble finding it just keep your eyes
on the radio mast it's right below that it's the peak that's
full of take a walk in the woods watch your steps so you
don't end up like max wait we have to watch out We got a
bunch of campers out there.
We haven't heard from.
Traps now, too.
But with the traps, well, you know, I just don't want any
trouble.
I love that the peak is surrounded by a mysterious fog, a
very ominous silent heel fog in that town.
Silent heel.
Kotaku!
It's customary to give spiritual offerings to your ocean.
Your birthday!
Have a crazy...
dream Kotaku happy birthday you're asking me to believe that
you shot a dude who went poof in the thin air a guy who was
bulletproof until you pointed a flashlight at him yep you
hear that from people who end up spending time in padded
rooms strapped to their beds wearing white shirts with too
long tangled up sleeves now he's dead and eating a healthy
diet of pills Al you make cruel jokes about people who
believe that kind of stuff you're the skeptic you gave me an
hour-long lecture on homeopathy last month what was it if
there's no proof it's pure bullshit period guess the laughs
on me then ow come on i mean dynamic camera angles okay
maybe something weird happened to you okay cougar well
thanks for the heartfelt vote of confidence all i'm saying
is you gotta throw me a bone here bestseller what would you
think if it was me there's no way you should be going out at
midnight with a gun no one else I'm gonna have my flash with
me on this or go straight back to New York your choice hot
and steamy on lovers peak oh yeah yeah all right bye Barry
bye Charlie all right now I have to remember how to play the
game shoot that's just crazy talk ow ow Al maybe Barry we
should go to the sheriff or call the FBI damn it Barry
they'll kill her this is not a goddamn debate Barry I'm
going to lovers peak he said to come alone okay okay then I
understand you're my best friend and I'm worried that you're
not right in the head tell me what to do to help and I'll do
it okay you stay here yeah if I'm not back by morning call
the cavalry what if out for another week okay just be
careful with the natives ow these yokels are dangerous why
keep calling them a yokel what is a yokel deliverance all
over again you're gonna be okay in here actually bless you
will he be all right oh this place is trying to kill me I'll
bet there's mold in here spores poison ivy God knows what
this is so not worth a 15% commission I'm wasting battery
here but you want to know where you can shove that
flashlight yeah yeah you go ahead and do what you have to do
i'll be fine okay alone but fine you could have it straight
from a horror movie i was gonna say you could turn on some
lights or something or actually this is like the worst
lighting in history or i have the strongest flashlight in
history like one or the other switch lights what does that
mean Oh.
Real funny, Al.
Real funny.
Ha ha.
Thank you.
I'll just sit here in the dark till you come back.
Or until I get eaten by a grue.
Oh, who?
The guy that's gonna steal the moon?
This reminds me of a cabin I stayed in once.
And everyone in my family had a dream that somebody...
was hanging from the rafters.
Creepy.
I guess I leave then.
Okay, I think I remember.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I was searching for stuff.
Okay, so I think this is to kind of dodge if I'm walking.
Or is it to run?
Actually, I'm not sure.
There was a dodge, though, wasn't there?
I guess No, this is just running.
Oh, I have stamina.
Hold on.
Run and dodge are the same button.
I don't remember.
I guess I can't...
I can't get my gun out yet or anything.
I'm just nervous about not knowing what to do, you know.
I'm trying to figure it out soon, but the game isn't...
The game is literally not allowing me to try anything.
I die?
I die.
At least know how to focus my light.
Oh my god, it's already spooky.
I'm knocking over everything.
Let's see.
It won't even let me change guns.
So do I have a gun?
Is a better question.
I'm not sure.
There's a Hot tub!
For me and Barry!
Let's go.
Spooky well.
Very out of place plastic chairs.
Let's move these.
I don't think you can be five feet apart in that tiny thing.
I think you have to be all over each other.
A little.
like i guess it'll just go then i was looking for a
manuscript but i don't see anything either did i pick up
anymore uh that i didn't read let me oh here we go the
kidnapper fired his gun one last time uh-oh the shadow
vanished into the darkness it had come from see nothing to
it wake wait what the thought of alice in his hands was
revolting we stood on the wooden platform of lover's peak
the waterfall in the mountain behind us the lights of the
radio mass blinking red in the heights above.
I fought with the urge to take a swing.
Force myself to speak.
Let's cut the act now.
Where's my wife?
Wait, you're forcing yourself to speak?
I don't think...
I think you speak very...
I think you're very excited to speak, uh...
Mr. Wake.
I think you'll speak at every opera...
Ugh!
Wait here, Al.
I'll hold down the fort.
I'll be with you in spirit every step of the way, Al.
What?
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Um, why can't I hear you from all the way over?
Oh, you're downstairs?
He really locked the door!
Oh my god, there he goes!
Okay, what if I...
For God's...
Oh my...
I have my gun now.
Okay.
Oh shoot, how do I...
Oh!
Sorry!
Yeah, I lost my flare and my shotgun.
No!
Okay.
I remember how to use the flashlight.
I see the manuscript down there.
Checkpoint reached, okay.
Let's see what this bad boy says.
Barry doubts wake stage.
Barry had never gotten along with Alice.
But he knew Alan loved her with an almost friend.
frightening intensity.
And now something had happened to Alice.
And here was Al armed with a gun and saying things people
got put in bad at sea.
Get that guy a fresh pair of pairs.
It was as if this friend had experienced a massive psychotic
episode and was now totally disconnected from reality.
It scared the shit out of Barry.
What?
Don't be scared.
More plastic.
More plastic chairs.
Belongs to Virgil, yeah.
Alright.
Guys.
I knew I should have gone to the cops.
This wasn't the smartest thing I'd ever done.
But I was still angry with Barry for trying to talk me out
of it.
These people had called me right in the sheriff's station.
The cops wouldn't scare them.
And they had Alice.
Are these the same kind of birds that will attack me?
They sure look like it.
These look like the kind of birds that are going to come
swooping down on me.
I have a feeling.
This game's a little spooky, guys.
And I wasted some bullets on accident.
That's a safe area right there.
Oh, what is over?
Oh, my God.
What is that?
Hello?
I'm scared.
This is such a nice area though.
Wow, the view is kind of crazy.
Okay, let's go upstairs, see if I can grab anything here.
There's something inside.
I'm just breaking and entering, sorry, excuse me.
Turn the lights on.
Yes.
Welcome back to the show, folks.
As promised, our very own Dr. Nelson has just parked his
rear end in the studio.
Dr. Nelson.
What's your Deerfest plan like?
My plan?
You'll make it sound a lot more organized than I ever seem
to manage.
Wasn't that funny?
I'm getting a little too much wickety to do much more than
that, you know?
Oh, tell me about it.
No sat race for us older gentlemen.
What was so funny?
but I'm gonna check out the parade of course and I'll be one
of the party contest judges ooh well that takes a different
kind of constitution oh yeah it's my kind of exercise now
doc seriously you're in pretty good shape though you're the
outdoors type I know for a fact you're an avid fisherman
yeah we know matter of fact just caught a heck of a large
mouth bass early this morning yeah but the fishing contest
no no not this year see pat i'm just not that competitive
anymore now i just like to take my time and enjoy the piece
of it it's no fun if i need to worry about what i'm catching
you know now considering your track record the participants
are probably pretty happy you feel that way well pat that's
kind of you to say okay that was cute Anything around here?
Doesn't seem like it.
Alright.
Just a whole lot of old people talk.
That's cute.
Let them oldsters yapp up for a bit, you know.
Let the old fellas talk.
Drop hazard!
Uh oh.
Why is that moving all of a sudden?
Huh?
Scary, creepy?
We love hags.
What is the opposite of a hag?
Geezer?
Just the wind.
It's getting stopped so quickly.
As soon as it started.
I'm hearing noises.
I'm scared.
Hold on.
I'm going to turn.
What's happening?
What?
What happened?
Uh.
No.
Actually, what happened?
Earthquake?
Uh.
Oh, no!
The light went out!
No!
My safety!
Lovers peek.
moonshine cave is that that away
earthquake I guess this this takes place in Washington right
I guess there would be earthquakes because it's along the
west coast going to make a wrestling show for my birthday
tonight and you're playing one of my favorite games lucky me
enjoy the remedy verse burger kund happy birthday oh this
place is doesn't look so.
Whoa, what happened here?
Oh, that don't look good.
Um, kick?
Okay.
Kick, kick it.
Allen, kick!
Allen!
What happened in here?
A bear?
Maybe?
The light switch doesn't work either.
Open!
Nothing?
Okay.
Use?
Oh, yay!
TBE!
TAB!
TASME!
Welcome to Bamboo Ship!
Thank you!
The cancer and cure of civilization!
But some crimes are impossible to punish.
Especially...
What is with the dust in there?
Little little loo!
Tonight's episode.
Ooh.
Opposite of hag, are...
Are what?
Do we?
No.
Talking about for a guy.
You're confessing to killing that guy, huh?
Why?
And he's coming?
Yeah, but why would you do that?
I mean, you're a nice guy.
Normal.
Took a kid to a soccer game.
So how come at the game, you pick a guy...
His voice does not...
Does not hit him.
...repeatedly with the weapon of choice being apparent.
of bare fists oh wow that sentence really flows huh it's unc
maybe you're not the literary type wouldn't it be geezer you
mess him up but why who was that guy we couldn't idea why
would a guy like you do him like that i didn't like his face
well you must have hated it because you really went to town
there i didn't like his face tell what he looked like no
idea on him either that must be difficult but then we ran
the fingerprints got a match your prince identical huh how
about that your son said you were wearing a white shirt when
you took him to the game the white shirt is on the dead guy
it's plenty red now I won't get away with this do you really
think that's in any way relevant to me I had plenty of time
to talk to my boy before the cops arrived you know he won't
stop screaming am I right you think he's gonna be okay what
is what is this I don't understand this either don't worry
oh maybe you see me again agent huh he's gonna punch him
What?
The first one was funny.
This one was silly too.
Shapeshifter?
Freaky.
Are they coming for me?
Oh, I can kind of like...
Oh, I am getting them though.
I was at... Oh, for a second.
Come on.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm taking care of them.
It's my birthday today too!
Just wanted to say a quick thank you for all the fun streams
and performances.
I always have the night to see Etsy!
Happy birthday!
Sorry, I swallowed my spear wrong.
Bad acting though, Oscar worthy.
Truly.
It was so good.
A car.
Abandoned car.
Wait, so this is the walking trail.
Can I call back Barry, Barry, how are you?
I miss you.
Oh, more birds.
Are these dangerous, danger birds?
No, no danger birds.
Checkpoint reached.
They were reading my manuscript.
What'd they think?
Rusty dying?
When the visitor center was heavy with an awful smell, as if
some rotten drowned thing had crawled up from its grave.
Rusty kept coughing blood.
My eyes were drawn to the twisted shape of his broken leg.
attack had been vicious max whined in his oh wait rusty is
the guy that with fear and terror he gasped mr wake it
happened just the way it was on that page the ranger yeah oh
my god wait rusty is gonna die
what's going on oh
the vision left me weak this was no head and
What?
Rusty, take him.
Rusty, hang on.
I'm coming.
Please, help me.
What is happening?
I'm coming.
I'm running.
What's that sound?
I don't want to think about it.
I'm just going.
Anybody?
Help me!
Rusty!
Whoa, holy cow.
Where are you?
Rusty?
Rusty.
I'm...
Oh, hold on.
There's something shining over here.
I'm helping.
And one second.
What's the cover?
Hold on.
One second.
Rusty attacked by the dark presence.
The visitor center was sturdy, but the impact turned the
front of the building into splinters.
Rusty was thrown across the lobby like a ragdoll and hit the
firewall hard.
It didn't hurt until he tried to move and saw his leg bend
the wrong way.
Felt the broken ribs stabbing him on the inside.
Rusty howled in pain and fear Suddenly afraid to die alone
Oh no, he won't die alone I mean, he's not gonna die at all,
I'll be right there I'm coming I'm coming I'm coming Wait,
how's Charlie?
In perfect condition, okay Oh my god Oh, Rusty
Mr. Wake Hello?
Oh, hell.
It happened.
Just the way it was on that page.
I found it.
True.
It knew.
So dark.
It'll come back for me.
You must.
The lights.
In the office.
I have the key.
Okay, Rusty.
Hang on.
I'll be right back.
Oh.
Rusty had found a page from the manuscript.
It would help me understand what had happened.
Are you okay, boy?
Shh.
Good boy.
Oh.
Charlie, okay?
Charlie is, like, in peak condition.
Charlie has no damages.
It's awesome.
This one.
It is this one, right?
Wait.
Get the lights on.
He said in the room, no?
Was it over here?
No?
Oh?
What's this?
Oh, nothing.
Oh, in the other building.
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh, cross the street.
The office?
Oh, okay.
The only way to make sure that Rusty was safe was to get the
power running and the lights back on.
Okay, I'm scared.
I'm scared.
Unlock, please.
is that what is that what is this oh my manuscript what does
it say is this the one where he gets attacked wake reaches a
safe haven of light i love that last instant i changed
direction and threw myself down the axe splintered the trunk
of a tree i stumbled into the pool of bright light my lungs
burned oh that's not good i was too exhausted to move i tend
no spoilers oh no spoilers please but it never came i'm not
looking thank you guys If you see spoilers...
If you see spoilers, do a smiley face and it'll show me that
there's spoilers and then also that...
It'll help push it off the screen too.
This is my first time playing, so please no spoilers.
Thank you, thank you.
Is that ammo?
It looks like...
I hear something in there.
Sounds like a...
like a scritchy scratch it's kind of nice sounding actually
oh here oh I was too late someone had destroyed the circuit
breaker no there was no way to get the lights back uh-uh
Rusty what's going on over there
That tree wasn't fallen before, was it?
The ground was covered with oily patches that looked like
liquid darkness.
Wait!
The dog!
Oh no, my god.
Oh shoot.
Very important.
Hold on, I'm getting rid of this oil.
Whatever the hell this is.
Max!
Something had torn a mammoth-sized hole in the wall.
Please don't feed the animals.
A mammoth size, you say.
Fishing is only permitted for those visitors who purchase a
park fishing license.
Is that Rusty?
Is Rusty possessed?
Rusty?
Max?
What?
Oh!
Mark Ranger's instructions?
Not all kinds.
Oh, he's... Rusty, no!
Rusty, no!
Two bears and wolves!
Never approach any other world war to go closer than...
Oh my god.
Ah!
It is against the law.
To remove any natural arms or historical remains.
Run apart.
Come on, come on, come on, come on, come on.
I forgot I can...
Okay, we got him.
Rusty!
Rusty is...
Oh!
Oh, shoot.
Oh, man.
There's more guys coming in.
Hey!
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Let's not do that.
Reload, reload, reload.
Yeah!
Okay, I'm remembering how to play the game.
Rusty?
Rusty, you...
I'm remembering how to play!
Yeah.
Sorry if it's really loud though.
I'm like trying, I can't really adjust the...
Oh yeah!
We got our... Yeah!
We got the...
um, the thing full of ammo.
The dumpster of ammo!
Yeah!
Volume's okay?
Okay, cool.
Thank you.
Yeah, because, um...
What was it?
The... Usually the voice...
Oh, wait.
What kind of ammo is this?
Well, let me pick it up.
Oh, it's milk.
What kind of ammo could it be?
Okay, I don't think there's anything else in here.
I think we gotta go where they came from.
Oh!
Oh,
it's not this darkness again that we experienced in the
very, very beginning of the game, is it?
Checkpoint?
Let's go.
Like... Oh, maybe.
This way?
It's really bright.
Oh.
Oh, shi-moshi.
The ammo for your buds.
Forget about it, Barry.
It's just me going crazy.
Oh, jeez.
You're not crazy.
I wish you were crazy.
$100.
But you're not crazy.
Ow, be careful.
Stay in the cabin.
Don't open the door for anyone.
I mean it.
Yeah.
Not even for me.
I'm crazy.
Okay.
What do we got here?
Rusty's final thoughts.
In that last instant of consciousness, Rusty thought about
Rose.
He was older than she was.
Rose was barely out of her teens.
But she made him feel young.
Oh.
He still wore the ring.
Oh, that's... Wait, wasn't he at the diner in the first
episode?
Oh, no.
Oh, Rusty.
Rusty, I know your marriage is exactly that.
A little rusty, but...
Come on, guy.
Just get the divorce.
It's okay.
Just get the divorce!
keep going.
We're going to Lover's Peak, but it looks like we're going
downhill.
What's this?
Oh, nice.
Okay,
good.
How do we get into the peak if we're going down?
Oh, it's that way.
Okay, wait.
There's a lot of checkpoints in this game.
At least he died with dignity.
I'm not complaining, by the way.
Yeah, I don't know if he did.
Lover's Peak was at the far end of the Entering Moonshine
Cave.
Wait, can we go in?
Oh, there's a hidden.
Whoa!
Whoa, we're in the cave, guys!
There's a hidden thing in here.
Oh, this is scary.
Sight of frequent bootlegger activity.
throughout the Prohibition.
This way?
Where at?
Oh, this thing?
Is that a shotgun?
Yippee!
We got a flare gun even!
Wow!
It was worth...
It was worth it.
What's all that noise, though?
You hear that?
It's kind of spooky.
I only have two bullets, though.
Okay, okay.
Read.
Oh, it was mostly used for a temporary storage of alcohol
smuggled from Canada.
But at times, alcohol was also distilled on the premises.
No, I think it's the birds that I'm hearing up there.
What the heck is that?
I think it's just all the birds that I'm hearing.
It's not the secret.
Whispering.
Wait, what's over here?
Anything?
Nothing.
Just fake light.
We can leave.
There was another pathway I meant to go earlier back at
the...
But it's okay.
I think I missed it, but that's alright.
Ha ha ha.
Kaka.
Them birds.
All right.
Lovers peak.
Ulla la la.
I keep thinking they mean like don't,
you know, like don't.
Why did that just fall?
Ah!
Oh my god.
Wait, what just happened?
Why did the camera do that?
Okay, thank you!
I don't need your assistance, I know where they are!
Oh.
There's three of them!
Ouch!
Oh my gosh.
That scared the heck out of me.
Ah!
The guy came from behind.
Oh.
Hello?
You assholes!
Oh, there's a light down there.
We gotta...
You heal!
Not so bad in this game.
It's actually...
Let's reload while I'm at it too.
Attacked from... from behind at Lover's Peak is crazy.
We're not even there yet!
We're not- we're not at Lover's Peak!
Do you think I'll meet my lover there?
Oh, Lover, my lover!
What's over here though?
There's another pathway.
Unless, this is the pathway I saw earlier.
No, it's not.
Manuscript.
This game really rewards you for exploring.
Barry meets Rose!
Nobody in Bright Falls seemed to know where Al was, but
Rose, the waitress at the diner, had seen him.
From what Barry could tell, pretty much fell off the face of
the earth when he left the diner rose was just the kind of
fan lovers plural but she really tried to help she was smart
too knew a lot about what was going on in the town knew a
lot about al even knew who barry was oh barry liked her that
was no big surprise when it came to women barry and al
rarely saw oh sorry whoops rarely saw eye to eye why is rose
why is everybody obsessed with rose a temptress.
I thought this was...
Okay, maybe this isn't the pathway I saw earlier.
That I mentioned that I missed earlier.
There's not many people in the town.
I guess that's fair.
Who?
Who's here?
Where?
Show yourself!
Where are you?
I'm scared!
I was scared!
Where are you?
There's guns here.
Shotgun ammo?
Take that out.
And a shotgun ammo?
Pick that up.
Nice.
Um.
Is it just the ambiance, I can't tell, quite honestly.
It seems too intense, right?
Or is it just the ambiance?
Okay.
Let's just keep going.
Hopefully I don't get ambushed.
Please!
Wait, I need more signs.
Where's Lover's Peak?
The Great.
AHHHHH!
Oh, they get... they get stronger, huh?
Oh my god, wait, oh!
Yeah!
Okay, I don't want it to be on my shotgun, though.
There we go.
Oh, here you are.
Ah!
Ouch!
Oh!
Yeah, don't throw your thing.
Oh my gosh.
The gray old one.
That's what they call me.
I'm getting spooked.
Wait, is this lover's peak?
Where are we?
These are the hiking trails.
Yeah!
Where's the other guy?
You.
Oh, shoot.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Where's lover's peak?
I guess we go down the trail.
Oh, yes, yes, yes.
Yeah, I need more signs.
Come on, gamer paint.
Another one!
Oh
my god, that was close.
Holy cow.
Oh my god, I'm almost out of ammo.
Wait!
This is bad!
I'm almost out of ammo!
I'm running.
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm
running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
No!
You!
Start, please!
Okay.
Alan, run.
Everyone's a critic.
Wait, wait.
What'd you say?
These are all of Alan Wake's critics.
Hey, I didn't like the way you...
You...
You uh shipped my you threw away my ship they call her the
great old one goo for sure very ectoplasmy Okay, ducky All
right Wait is that there's some ammo here Thank goodness I
need it Please open Alan open Revolver ammo Batteries.
Okay, two things that we definitely needed.
What's going on here?
They axed the phone!
All they said is I must ask you a question!
Local rider visits small town for a vacay, proceeds to wipe
out half the population.
Yeah, sounds about right.
How far is lover's peak?
My god!
At this point, every level...
lover is gonna you know what they call it lover's peak
because they you have to go through the trials and the
tribulations of finding it you have to test your
relationship it's like you know how they say that couples
that go on vacation together or something is like the
ultimate test of your relationship that's exactly what this
is all the shadowy enemies are actually alan's family what
it's not the destination it's the journey exactly this is
the true test to make that you are compatible for your
relationship I turned the corner afraid of what the
flashlight's beam might reveal suddenly a roughly painted
symbol of a torch glowed in the light oh behind it hidden by
a rock sat a battered metal trunk yeah yeah yeah it was here
for a reason pack was yeah I found these before ammo things
you need to make it through the darkness of the night
something left behind by someone who knew what I knew and
more that is true who's Wake sees the torch symbol.
That's not even like...
Is it part of the lore?
Actually, it might be.
Huh.
I forgot what... There was an easy mode for this game,
wasn't there?
Bear alert!
Whoa, what was that?
Uh, did you see that?
Wait, did you guys see the building that was behind my head?
Wait a second, what was that?
I wonder what it is.
The music is killing me.
Checkpoint reached.
Am I going to get attacked by a bear?
No kidding.
Lover's peak!
Oh, lava!
That was Bigfoot.
Oh, come on.
I'm not doing so hot guys Holy cow Where are they?
I don't even think I got them before Because Oh my god
Please I
don't even think I got them before Because I didn't get
their What's it called?
Their shield down Aw man Oh well it to just get them off my
tail for two seconds stay on designated hiking trail for my
safety sure
sure the flare gun kills the shield oh it does that's good
to know i wish it would let me reload while i'm not in you
know battle that went well actually are you just saying that
is this a trail I think I'm just in the woods right now.
Wait.
Did I say a yellow?
No.
I saw a plant.
Spy fiction.
MGS ripoff.
I'm the creator of Deadly Premonition.
I don't know this, actually.
Sounds funny, though.
Thank you for the Silver Talos.
Oh.
No lovers allowed.
Oh, man.
Always making me go the long way.
I only have two batteries left.
This is not good.
The game's getting pretty intense.
What is this?
It just said, oh, it's just a log.
That dates from 1846.
The year of the Oregon Trail.
Oh, wow.
The tree ring.
The tree this ring was cut from started growing in 1846.
Other notable events marked on the rings.
Washington Treaty.
No, Washington Territory was formed.
The founding of the Bright Falls Mining Co.
in the town itself in 1878.
Good.
So welcome back.
Thank you.
Washington was granted statehood.
Tree damaged in a forest fire.
The Bright Falls Mining Co.
its doors after a volcanic eruption below Cauldron Lake.
Mount St. Helens erupts.
Tree felled.
Damn.
The tree survived a forest fire.
Two volcanic eruptions and falls over because of a storm.
That's pretty tragic.
Wait a second.
I wasn't supposed to go over here?
Is there anything in the dumpster, please?
Say yes.
No.
Dang.
Um.
Yeah, it survives so much just for a storm to take it out.
Oh.
Uh.
Hey, Alan, think I need you to have a genius author idea,
please.
Oh, wait.
Can I go over the fence?
Oh, I can!
What?
I had the genius thought.
Sees Mito streaming while I'm working in the office, clicks
in immediately met with a scream.
Solid Snake!
Thank you for the super chat.
Good luck with work!
Alan Dink.
Alan Reed.
Nightingale's arrival.
Agent Nightingale didn't want to be in Bright Falls.
These little communities revolted him.
Oh my gosh, no, thank you for the pink!
One second, I'll read it in a second.
He now knew that impossible horrors lurked behind the
storefronts and smiles.
He desperately wanted to turn the car around and just drive
until he passed out or ran out of road and booze.
but he had a job to do he had a rider to catch at any cost
um hello why are we catching me some context since i didn't
explain very well yesterday oh oh yeah a co-worker and i
were pulled over because he was driving high the company
truck was impounded so the cops gave us a ride to town i was
put in the back because i'm shorter than the driver i see it
Thank you for the context.
Well, I'm glad you're okay.
That your co-worker didn't cause any harm to you or anyone
else.
Where are we?
Lovers peak.
We're so far from where we started.
Recovered by card and bamboo ship.
Let's go have a nice dream and keep going.
Guys!
Oh my god, well, I'm glad you got your card back.
That's more important, I'd say.
Have a nice day!
Thank you!
Burgers or pizza, Minto?
Always burgers.
Alright, here we go.
Are we gonna get attacked by birds while we're in here?
I'm vigilant Alan
fall oh my god Alan grab Alan your flashlight
We were saved who are you come on we got to get moving more
of them coming what who are you Oh my gosh that flashlights
kid stuff.
Sorry.
It's all I got players will keep the bastards away Okay
Friend!
Oh my gosh.
You can see them too?
Hell of course I see them.
Come on, we gotta move.
Okay, hold on.
Why?
Because that's the way the story goes.
Yeah, but...
Let's move.
Okay.
I lost my gun back there.
I did?
Oh, I've got a gun.
Oh, shoot.
Just keep that light steady on him.
R.V.
You do?
He'd been on the ferry when I first arrived here with Alice.
Oh, what is this guy?
We were headed in the direction of Lover's Peak.
There was no way this was a coincidence.
He was the kidnapper.
Come on, Wake.
Wait a second.
You set him up and I'll knock him down, Wake.
I don't think that's it.
Guy who robbed me last night.
Wait, oh my gosh.
I'm gonna die?
Um, can you help me?
Oh, what's here?
What's going on?
Uh, oh, visual glitch?
Uh, I think I'm...
Wait.
Hold on.
Uh, the game went black again.
This happened before.
Hold on, let me, like, open up a manuscript and see if maybe
that'll get, uh...
It's true what they say.
Okay, maybe, maybe, maybe now we're good.
Okay, here we go.
Oh, where are you?
Oh.
Ouch, why me?
Wait,
wait, where are we going?
This way?
Oh.
Ouch.
Get some!
Here?
What am I supposed to do here?
What are we supposed to do here?
Oh, I don't think I'm...
I think I need them to come closer.
Follow the kidnapper.
Is that it?
Ah!
Oh my gosh, that scared me.
Yeah!
What the heck?
How did it...
How is it doing that?
I don't...
I don't know what we're supposed to do.
Hello?
I think that was the last one.
There we go.
Use the flares from the emergency box to hold them off while
I get these boards off.
Oh, we're out of flares.
Wait.
Wait, we're out of flares.
Are you kidding?
Wait!
Give me the gun.
Oh, no.
No time for backtalk.
Hold them off, damn it.
Uh-oh.
Guys, I think we're, uh, screwed.
I can't...
Yeah, we're so screwed.
Wait, we're so screwed.
Oh my god.
He's right on me.
Wait, wait.
Excuse me.
Hold on.
I don't have a gun!
We're so screwed.
We're so...
I'm so screwed.
Okay, I have three.
Okay.
What?
Ow, John.
Okay, let's not waste all of our...
Can you actually aim, please?
Yeah.
Can we please aim?
That's right.
Okay, I think that...
Alright.
Okay.
Thank you for the redirect!
I'm in a bit of a panic right now!
Are you kidding?
Give me the gun!
No time for back talk!
Hold him off, damn it!
Okay!
I'm gonna do my best!
Hold down.
Just a little longer.
Scare them off.
Ha!
Get some light on those bastards.
That's my last one.
Last one, mister.
Okay.
Now we're screwed.
Oh, we're screwed.
We're screwed.
Go, go, go, go!
Go, go, go, please.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die.
Yeah,
actually.
No, no thanks to you.
You could have given me like 15 more flares, please.
Better get ready.
They'll be on us soon.
I have ready how?
I have nothing with nothing on me.
Is this it?
Is this our lover's seat?
Oh.
Last stand.
Get ready!
We fight them as long as they keep coming.
Oh, okay.
Give me the goddamn gun!
They're coming!
That's not how this goes.
Get with a program, wait.
Oh!
Oh my god, I tried to...
I see a thermos!
Stop moving.
Okay, sorry.
I wish I had a gun.
It'd be really cool.
Right now.
Why don't you know how to aim, man?
Mr. I need you to learn how to aim.
Okay, while you get this guy, I'm gonna get the thermos.
I don't think I can get the thermos.
Oh my god!
Ah!
Ouch!
Yeah, you saw it.
He shoots where I am?
No way.
Really?
Wait, I have no more flares.
We're screwed.
Oh my gosh!
Ouch!
We're so screwed.
we're so screwed we're so screwed oh my god ouch please
please oh my god i'm trying to dodge i can't dodge ah
there's more flares here get rid of them as long as they
keep coming oh shoot no please give me the goddamn gun
they're coming that's not how this goes this is messed up
this is so messed up oh my god oh my god they're like get
rid of their shields like like this he doesn't know how to
aim though this guy seriously doesn't know how to aim ouch
ouch please
please mister please mister just kill him Oh my gosh.
Ah!
Oh shoot.
We did not get you.
Ah!
Where's my friend?
Not friend.
Where are- Ouch!
Oh my god, please!
Oh, I'm gonna die again.
This is so hard!
Oh!
Where are they?
I can't even see anything!
Can we get this guy, please?
Oh!
God, please!
Why?
Ah!
Stand.
There's more flares here.
Get ready.
Guys, this is so hard.
Give me the goddamn gun.
They're coming.
This is so hard.
Ow!
I wasted a flare already.
Oh shit.
This is so stinking hard!
No, no, you will not.
Oh my god, I'm trying to dodge!
For real!
Oh my god, please, just kill him.
Yeah!
Okay.
Oh, it's so hard.
This guy can't aim worth shit.
He seriously can't aim.
Okay.
Oh, piece of cake, okay.
Oh my god.
Backseat him.
I'm trying.
Oh, I swear.
I swear I'm trying.
There we go.
Yeah, get his ass.
Please,
please, please, please, please.
Die already, please.
Oh, that's a big guy.
Oh, my God.
Please, kill them.
Please kill them.
Oh, my God, please.
Ah!
I can't move.
Oh.
This guy is...
sucks he doesn't know how to aim shoot there shoot that guy
shoot this guy oh shoot him in a second hold on shoot shoot
him now i'm literally i'm literally like directing the light
at them oh i think i accidentally used a flare oh no i
didn't mean to i didn't mean to use the flare
I'm so ass!
This is the worst game ever!
And sometimes I can't tell who's him?
And who's like...
Who's him and who's like one of the zombie guys?
Because they're all dressed the same.
Okay, alright, alright.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Okay, I have one player left.
Ouch!
Use the flare, please!
Am I... Am I... Do I need to... Why are they not getting
distracted by the light?
Oh, please!
I'm trying to dodge!
Oh, it's this guy!
Oh, it's the big guy!
Holy shit!
Oh my god.
Don't come after me, though!
Get him?
Get his ass?
Please?
Oh, my God.
Oh, we did it.
Oh, I'm so sweaty.
I'm so sweaty.
Let's cut the act now.
Oh, my God.
Where's my wife?
I knew you were going to say that.
I read it all before.
You're out of your life.
Congratulations.
You're going to think about something glorious and terrible
once we get you some proper editorial control.
Oh.
What the hell are you talking about?
Where's Alice?
I want the entire manuscript.
Well, she's gonna suffer bad.
You touch her mouth.
Oh, damn.
Oh, wow.
Good job.
Can I have a gun back, please?
Nice.
Oh, my gosh.
That was suffering.
Oh, the gun!
Hey, everyone.
Thank you so much for the fire gifted.
Guys, that was painful.
I can't imagine that on Nightmare.
mode.
You're gonna give me the manuscript or you'll be sorry.
No!
Come back here!
I swear I'll kill you if you heard Alice!
Do you hear me?
Come back here!
Me walking at a snail's pace.
He had Alice.
And he wanted the manuscript because he thought it held some
magical power.
But I had no manuscript to give him.
I had to get back to Barry and figure out my next move.
Thank you.
Thank you for the five gifted.
Alice's fear of the dark.
On more than one occasion, Alice had tried to explain to me
how it felt to be afraid of the dark.
I need a second to breathe.
I love rage games, especially when I'm not playing them.
It was something you could touch and feel.
Most of that, it was something with a mind of its own.
Something malicious and malign.
For her, things changed when they were wrapped in darkness.
They turned into something else.
Something foreign.
And nothing was safe or innocent anymore.
Krish, thank you so much for the thank you for that.
I think it would have been if I had it like I didn't know
how to use the flares before and so I just wasted a ton of
them and so I was left with very few in the end can I just
like go down here?
Oh, maybe I shouldn't where does that go?
Wait, maybe I have to go that way oh no kidding, I have to
go that way that's so funny I kept trying to tell you you.
I don't know what you guys want from me.
To play the game or read chat constantly.
Air out them pits now.
Oh.
Okay, I'm dropping.
Where are we dropping, boys?
Good job.
Oh.
Am I not supposed to get on top of this thing?
Let's try again.
One second, before I deal with...
Oh!
I see what the direction...
The direction I was supposed to go.
I'm just going this way to make sure I didn't miss any
items.
Oops.
It's okay, we made it, whatever.
We did it!
Alan's sequence break.
I promise not...
Will you marry me?
I promise not to take you to a creepy town with a creepy
forest and trap you in a creepy nightmare dimension by
writing a creepy story.
Oh, Bigfoot strikes again.
What is this?
Ah!
What the hell?
Oh!
Oh my god, please!
That was cruel.
Ah.
Alan stuck.
Not- why would you put it in the middle of the hiking path?
I'm sorry, that's psychotic.
Ah!
Another one!
Psycho behavior!
How am I supposed to- okay, eye on the ground?
This is actually how I usually walk though, just looking
down.
Oh, look at all of them!
Oh my gosh, it's a minefield!
Oh, this is evil!
What the hell is this?
What is this?
Wait, can I walk?
I don't want to run into it.
Oh my god!
I'm going very slowly.
Okay.
Uh.
Oh my god.
This is actual psycho behavior.
If you go prone, you can pick up the mines.
I know!
I wish!
This is insane!
Mindsweeper trained you for this.
Focus M!
What is that?
Why?
Focus M.
Wait, what's over here?
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
I don't think I've trained for this.
Double tap for zombies, quadruple tap for bears.
It's a meme from Triple A Mario.
What?
What's that?
I see a house.
Okay, I'm just gonna start walking forward and hope and
pray.
Why would you lead me this direction if there's nothing
here?
Can I get them birds?
I don't want to waste my battery.
They're being evil birds again.
I'm trying to make it through the woods, everybody.
Oh!
Oh my gosh, manuscript!
And actual item?
Actual items?
Not just traps?
Actual things!
Yeah!
Revolver ammo!
Batteries!
What is that?
Oh, Revolver ammo.
We take, we take.
Um...
And then... Manuscript.
Can I grab that?
Oh yeah.
Oh my god, be careful, please!
Alan...
No fear.
Alan Read!
thinks about Wake.
Sarah didn't care about the legal threats Wake's agent had
made.
I'm still recovering from that last bit, man.
Because there was something about him she couldn't quite put
her finger on.
Something that reminded her of her father.
She didn't think Wake would hurt his wife.
Then she thought about the way he waited into Hartman.
That hair trigger rage flaring up without warning.
Hmm.
Daddy issues?
the cans can be shot yeah but i don't want to waste ammo i
mean i'm not not that i'll waste it but you know i'll shoot
it it's fun
we've seen them before i just never shot them before
i'm searching for traps who set all these up i just i have a
question for you
oh i have to go across you Imagine they put the traps on the
bridge as well.
Also, this is not a bridge.
This is not a very good hiking trail.
That's how I think about it.
This is a hiking trail!
Hmm.
Are we still on- this clearly seems like a trail.
I'm scared.
I'm scared of the traps.
Okay.
Oh.
Wait, where are- Ah!
God!
Oh!
Uh, uh, clear- Oh my god.
Where are you?
Where are you guys?
Oh,
make it through the woods is such an understatement.
You know!
What?
What's happening?
What's going on?
Wait, that doesn't seem good.
Uh, shoot.
Oh, what a time to need to reload my weapon!
Does it ever end?
There's too many campers out here.
And now I also have to look out for bear traps and
everything.
Going the wrong way.
Can't follow the gamer paint.
Dun, dun, dun, dun.
Yeah, what the hell?
Good question.
What the hell?
What the heck is going on here?
Oh my god.
Where'd you go?
Oh,
can I...
Okay, good.
Oh, we were still in, we were still in, like, the fight
mode, so I was able to, uh, reload.
Luckily, where, where am I going?
This way?
I guess I gotta follow the...
the yellow dot, right?
Make it through the woods, everybody.
That's all they say.
Make it through the woods and you'll be okay!
Oh!
Oh god!
Ouch!
Oh, I tried to dodge!
Oh, why are you so strong?
Ah, please!
Why are you so strong?
Oh my gosh.
I just wanted to turn on the lights!
I knew they would come.
They do this every time.
Oh, sorry.
That was me going.
Yippee!
I'm almost out of battery.
Golly!
Jump for joy!
Woo!
Yippee!
You think Barry's still...
Okay, that guy?
You think he's still around?
What's this?
Is that a door?
Oh.
we get in here.
Why is he jump like that?
This is a happy guy.
It's me.
Alan wake!
Alan jump.
Where have I got more?
Oh, thank goodness.
Are those bear traps on the tree?
Evil.
Thermos.
I couldn't...
I didn't know how to grab the thermos.
During that one scene where we were getting ambushed.
on at lover's peak if you want to be my lover you gotta get
with my zombies wait this is something flashy here nope
um hunting rifle new gun
is there ammo for this bad boy wait what about my shotgun oh
i lost that that's right we lost the shotgun i lost all my
stuff wake here's a chainsaw the night had been one
desperate situation after another i was exhausted and my
body felt as though it had been chewed up and spat out the
flashlight was heavy in my hand and each pull of the can
also only carry the rifle or shotgun at once yeah it was
finally out of the woods and things were looking up uh-oh
that's when i heard the chainsaw oh no Okay.
Zombie ship never ends.
Oh, oh no.
What happens to my arm?
Oh, geez.
Chainsaw.
Love that for us.
Big fan, big fan.
Oh, I can reload.
I'm a liar.
Maybe...
I don't know what I was thinking.
oh oops that's not what i meant to do i'm guessing i just
drop here
i don't see it i don't see a path though but
it has to be right it looks like i need to get over to where
that light is down there where are we dropping boys here
apparently i guess i wouldn't have this to lead us here if
if it weren't for that you know is that a plane
I think that's a plane you guys see that
whoa Alan fly I think I have to go this way oh folks What am
I focusing on?
What am I focusing on?
I had heard the plane fall.
It made no sense.
It was clear that it had just fallen here.
But it was very old and obviously hadn't flown with decades.
Looking at it, sent a shiver down my spine.
That's what we heard!
Interesting.
Rock ASMR?
Okay.
Checkpoint.
We love those.
I look like I'm in the jungles.
I'm looking for any secrets.
Any, like, whispers?
I don't hear any.
Oh, I went out of here.
For realsies!
Ouch!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Fire.
Yeah.
Wait, where is he?
Oh, jeez.
Ouch!
Ouch, I tried to dodge!
Don't you dare.
Yeah!
Jeez.
Holy!
Make it out of the woods.
So much easier said than done, huh?
More!
Oh my gosh, I saw him appear literally in front of me.
Wee!
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
We switch the spawn in.
Give me a moment's respite.
Oh, Lee.
I thought the game, the first time it was very generous
with, like, everything.
Now it's a little tricky.
It's actually quite tricky.
don't have much battery left and it's not giving me any more
that's scary first chapter did not have this much combat
there I'm getting ambushed by like four guys every time it's
crazy and people said that this game is not the type where
you avoid combat that they're that they're quite generous
with like giving you stuff but I'm getting like I'm getting
I'm getting I'm getting winded here and there's obviously a
guy around still I can't believe they made the whole level
out of the expression we're not out of the woods yet and I
need to go that way okay oh I see a house I'm
just gonna run for it
thermos where are you I hear you guys Maybe I don't.
Maybe it's the spooky wind.
Maybe it's spooky wind.
Oh.
Alan run.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Oh please.
My battery.
Ouch.
What do I...
What do they do when I'm out of batteries?
What am I supposed to do?
Oh my god.
How am I supposed to get rid of their...
Oh, okay.
That's the recharge.
It still slowly recharges.
Oh, jeez.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, I see it.
I see it.
Golly.
It's tough.
No battery here?
Nothing?
Just a free...
Was I just walking off the trail?
Oh, checkpoints.
Oh, oops.
Did I just explode in the water?
What are you thinking about the game so far?
Are you enjoying it?
Yeah, I am.
I am.
Oh, it is tough, though.
I'm not gonna lie.
Oh my gosh.
It's pretty tricky.
Ow!
Now I miss.
Now I'm in a spooky house.
Is this anything?
No.
Yeah, it does have rough sections.
It's...
It's tough.
Oh.
Oh, some more of this stuff.
Reach the top of the mill.
Keep running up that road.
Keep running up that mill.
Is this an elevator?
It is.
Wee!
Ouch!
Oh my gosh.
Oh, you can't step on it.
It's evil goop.
The goop is evil.
Understood.
I've learned my lesson.
Okay.
Evil oil.
Um...
Oh, more?
Yes.
Let's see, let's go up this staircase first real quick.
Alan.
Oh, okay.
That's what I thought it would be.
Oh, oh, I could kick this.
And then it- oh, it will- oh, okay.
Wait, before we do that, let's explore over here.
what's that uh bendy and the ink machines is alan and the
foot goop oh okay i thought there i knew there would be
something manuscript page but not a lot of you know what
maybe it's not so bad that there's not a lot of supplies
because that means um hopefully hopefully that means that
we're not about to fight a big baddie the foot goop deputies
at the logging site The logging site was a mess.
The modular office had been pushed off the cliff.
Deputy Thornton climbed up from the wreckage excited,
breathing hard from the exertion.
Nobody there.
It's weird.
Don't you think that's weird?
Bored, Mulligan let out a mighty snort.
Hell, it's always weird, Thornton.
Just a question of sorting out what kind of weird it is this
time around.
Why are you guys frowning?
Why are we frowning?
I would really appreciate like a battery at the very least.
Kick.
Oh, there we go.
Been playing this on and off for years.
For about 15 years.
Did you beat it?
Wait, can I jump this?
Alan jump.
Nice.
Oh, Alan jump again.
All right, we got another manuscript to read.
Oh, Barry.
When Barry saw the darkness attack the visitor center, it
made him a believer.
The men all said he'd shot.
They hadn't been just locals on Crank.
Somehow the world had changed.
Like the channel had been switched without warning.
You think you're watching a sitcom and you're really
watching a horror show.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
When the birds started attacking the cabin, Barry wasn't
surprised.
Just terrified.
I think I would still be surprised.
Why are the birds attacking the cab?
Like, even the birds!
That's what I'd be thinking.
Even the birds are in on this?
That's what I'd be, I'd be like, no way!
Oh, we got some flares, though.
I'll take those, for sure.
No ammo.
How much?
Okay.
Uh, thermos?
What?
Why?
What spooky music?
What?
Where do I go?
Oh, there's a stair- or ladder.
Even the birds!
Alright, more goop.
Take care of that, take care of that.
The birds are the evil- are the boss this time.
Maybe I wasn't so off on that.
Maybe the birds are the boss this time.
Is that a hole?
Does that go down?
Whoa.
Not the chunky bird.
Thank you for the super challenge.
Thank you.
Oh, oh.
Almost there, I think.
look at all that poo the birds really hate this place
checkpoint okay thank goodness the darkness wears her face
what's that mean so the lady that lady that we've seen in
the dark in the be aware of wheelbapers oh gosh this is a
big guy.
Oh, shoot.
I meant to hold it.
Oh, no.
I just wasted both of them.
That's so funny, isn't it?
Isn't that, like, hilarious?
It's fine if I have to redo this part.
Alan waste.
I'm still getting used to the flares.
I can't believe I wasted both of them.
I like panic.
Panic used them.
Oops.
I can only blame myself there.
Hunting rifle.
Thank you.
Alan panic.
Alan jump.
Aha!
Pick it up.
Oh, another manuscript.
Gosh, this guy is just yapping and riot in wake feels the
dark presence shadow stirred and the wind picked up as i ran
through the forest i felt the dark presence turning its gaze
toward me then the moonlight was blotted out by dark shadows
that raised violently across the ground moving too swiftly
to be natural darkness gathered between the trees and melt
again to reveal the taken no no i don't like these i don't i
don't like this Um, did you guys, what was that movie?
A Darkness Falls, I think it was called.
It was about, like, the Tooth Fairy.
But she only would come out in the darkness.
That's what this reminds me of a little bit.
It's a pretty old horror movie.
But I remember it very vividly because, like, it scared my
friend.
so much.
And so I always thought of it as a very scary movie because
my friend was so scared of it.
It terrified me as a kid.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, how do I...
Oh, here we go.
Hey!
Those sound like bats.
Those Those don't sound like bones.
Oh, thank goodness.
Oh, we have a battery again.
We have two batteries.
Oh, thank goodness.
Um, I guess I'm...
The yellow points in this...
Oh, I see.
But what's this way?
Anything?
A cave?
Nope.
Just a red herring.
Make it through the woods.
I would like a different objective, please.
I'm done with the woods.
I don't like the woods anymore.
Ah!
Oh, come on.
Ouch!
Oh, you're too far, huh?
Is that what it is?
Oh shoot.
Oh my god, no.
Switch weapon.
Oh my god.
He's a big boy.
I didn't even notice that he was a big boy.
Man, our batteries.
Those guys could like eat up batteries.
They're crazy.
I don't know how I survived that at all.
Honestly, how did we make it?
I don't know.
They were just like...
I don't know how we made that.
I don't know.
But we did.
Weeer.
Oh, come on.
You won't let me climb the logs.
I hear more.
Rocks shifting.
We're almost back to camp, maybe?
Oh, four.
Bore batteries!
Please.
Oh, okay.
We have too much.
Revolver.
Oh, flare.
We're getting there.
Yeah, the campgrounds.
We're almost back.
This is a really nice...
This is, like, an extremely nice...
Uh...
What's the word?
National Park?
Oh.
Well, it would be so nice if someone wasn't chopping down
all the trees.
awesome this looks like a this looks like a paintball arena
or something what's going on here wait do i have to i don't
have to there's no way i can climb up that
oh i hear the chainsaw that's not how that should work oh my
god there's a couple of them
He's too far, I guess.
And flare!
Wait, can you like...
Yeah, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god, oh my god!
Run!
Oh my
god, I'm stuck on something!
Scary.
There's gotta be a dumpster full of ammo around here, right?
Right.
He was a biggin.
Yeah, he was.
No dumpsters?
Like a little mini boss.
And we still have one battery somehow.
Amazing!
How do we do it?
The world feels so open.
intimidating.
Like, I want to just go into the wilderness.
But I know I shan't.
Like, probably not wise.
Light.
Oh, he's calling me.
Hello?
Barry?
Stay out of sight.
I'm on my way.
Don't open the door.
What is it, crazy?
Stay hidden.
I'll be there soon, make sure you keep the lights on yeah
keep the lights on oh what's going on what was that they've
gone hitchcock on them
where i'm okay so we're at the camping ground oh hello yes
whoa oh there must i still had to reach barry at the cabin
but at least I was out of the woods.
Are we?
Oh, I guess technically we are.
Oh, we're out of the woods.
We did it, everybody.
We did it.
A lot of birds.
What's this?
Is this a car?
I'd have to get the car from the locked garage.
It would get me back to bury faster.
Yeah.
And the headlights were a welcome bonus.
Okay, find the garage keys.
Great, collision.
Good.
Pretty sure this was supposed to be an open world game at
some point, so that makes sense.
Oh, really?
Yeah, like it just feels like, you know, it's pretty linear
in where it tells you to go and everything too, but there's
also, so much that I feel like I I feel like I can explore
but I don't think there's anything back there so that's why
I don't go to explore it Allen out of the woods Nightingale
fires at wake uh oh wait that doesn't sound so good FBI
agents command FBI I considered surrender it was all falling
apart anyway wait I could give in let someone else deal with
it but it felt all wrong cold instinct his posture the way
he held the gun he was no friend Whoa.
Shots ringing in my ears.
I leap for the hole in the fence and stumbled into the
darkness beyond.
Yeah, we've had several things about this guy and we haven't
even met him yet.
Mr. Nightingale.
I'm already suspicious of you.
I had to find the key to the garage.
I'm working on it.
I wonder...
I hope I don't have to drive the car myself.
Because that won't go so well, I think.
Like, I think it will be very good.
I needed the garage key to get to the car.
Okay, but like, where is it that I'm searching?
Maybe, oh, you know what?
Let me go search the bathrooms.
I was thinking it might be inside one of these, but...
He thinks I'm leaving.
No, I'm just exploring.
I'm working on it.
What's that sound?
Let's go in this one first.
Oh, oh, this one's spookier.
Even though the lights are on, it's like a creepy...
What was that?
Is there a bird in here?
Yeah, horror always happens in the bathrooms.
You're so right.
No, I'm scared.
I gotta be brave.
Oh, I've gotta be...
Okay, here I go.
What do you mean checkpoint reached?
In the bathroom?
What do you mean by that?
Why is there a checkpoint in the bathroom, please?
Oh.
TV.
What?
This...
Is this a shower room?
Garage keys!
Okay, wait.
Before I get these, though, I want to go into the other
side.
How to make the bathroom not scary.
Peep, peep, peep, peep.
If this is a shower room, why is there a TV in here?
Wouldn't it get wet and stop working?
All right, let's go to the other side first before I grab
those keys and trigger whatever's going to happen.
You know?
Oh, my God.
Wait, there's no toilet seats in this one.
Why?
Why are there no toilet seats in here?
You just go in a hole in the ground, maybe.
There's also...
No TV.
I guess it did say that it was under construction, didn't
it?
So I guess that makes sense.
Alright, so we got the hunting ammo.
We love to see it.
Alright, let's go.
Let's go trigger whatever is going to trigger from me
picking this up.
Yeah.
a story is not a machine that does what you tell it a story
is a beast with a life of its own you can create it shape it
but as the story grows it starts wanting things of its own
change one thing and you set off a chain reaction of events
that spreads through the whole thing the characters have to
be true to themselves the events need to follow a logic that
fits the story a single flaw and the magic is gone the story
dies Alice dies Have you guys like...
Oh my god, the TV has exploded.
It doesn't work.
It's just...
Uh-oh.
Have you guys seen all the like drama with the ending of
Stranger Things?
And like this thing called Conformity Theory?
Oh my goodness.
I...
i only watched like maybe the first two seasons of stranger
things so i wasn't i liked it when i watched it but i wasn't
so into the show or anything so basically i haven't heard
the theory so basically the ending of the show was so bad to
people they thought it was so bad there were so many plot
holes that were like left unanswered so many things um that
like the fandom essentially kind of uh so so one thing about
stranger things from the beginning they were like question
everything nothing is a coincidence there's always a reason
if something is there and it's not it doesn't seem right
there's always a reason for it questioned everything and so
they came up with this thing called conform the conformity
theory that like um because they feel they thought that
there would be one final episode that was actually the real
finale to the show and that the the current finale of the
show is like one of the characters is actually being mind
controlled and or something I don't know and like the the
writers they did like they did like post series interviews
and they were like what and people would ask questions like
what was up with this and they'd be like oh we don't know
But people are like, you wrote the show.
Why don't you know?
And so it's kind of insane how like it became such a big
thing that people were like pointing out little tiny
details.
And I mean really tiny details.
So like so tiny.
Like in season one, the door handle was on this side of the
door.
But in season five, the door handle was on the other side of
the door, are in an alternate universe and it's not real
things like like that tiny of details that they were like
this is this is not real this is not the real ending and
then netflix hinted at like something coming out on the on
january 7th and and so everyone was like the real final
episode is to come january 7th and uh it's the 10th as of as
of this moment it's kind of insane how like how how they had
to cope so bad zadornov yeah
uh i watched the final episode it was fine it wasn't
fantastic but it ended pretty much as i expected i don't
know anything like people were of course for most things or
for a lot of things i won't say most but um it can be pretty
difficult people will always have different kinds of
expectations for what they expect for an ending of a show so
obviously you're not gonna be able to please everybody i
don't even know understand what everybody's so upset about
stranger things post credit scene yes mr president How is it
that Breaking Bad is the only show not to mess up their
ending?
Oh my gosh!
New silk sanity just dropped.
It's kind of really fascinating to just see like all this.
And I feel bad for Stranger Things fans that like didn't
like the ending and are, you know.
You know, I feel bad for them because they really like the
show.
And if you don't like the ending, like that's always a
little, that's always a little icky, right?
But it's kind of so.
had a good ending but what about our six seasons and a movie
Sherlock oh yeah Sherlock also Mass Effect Game of Thrones
fans first time oh wait is that I've never heard that the
Mass Effect ending is bad uh-oh very MGS 5 coded yeah yeah
yeah yeah I watched I'm on episode or rather I watched
episode 13 of Breaking Bad yesterday and I said that I would
watch 14, 15, 16 on stream.
I would do a watch along.
But that means I need to set aside three hours to do that.
To also, and then maybe also to have a stream.
So I've been trying, I was like, maybe I do it today.
But I was like, I can't do it before stream.
I don't have time.
So I'm like, dang it.
Scrubs had a beautiful ending after eight seasons.
And that's a good ending for like a beloved TV show.
is like the best thing you could ever ask for or a good or a
beloved video game so
so I might I don't have time tomorrow either so maybe Monday
I wasn't going to stream on Monday but if it's just a watch
along you know promised Neverland anime had a good ending
shame they never did a second season wait I thought people
didn't I like the Promise Neverland anime.
Or was it the manga?
I don't remember.
Mass Effect 3 ending was legendarily bad and had a lot of
controversies like this.
But I guess it happened before your gaming time.
Maybe, uh.
But.
Oh.
Woo!
What did he say?
What'd that guy say?
You can learn something about myself?
People were but hurt about Mass Effect 3.
It's crazy.
Promise Neverland's manga developed in a way I wasn't
expecting.
I heard, like, controversy about that, too.
Enter!
Uh-oh, wait.
I have to drive?
Uh-oh.
Wait, do I have to drive?
Uh-oh, wait.
This looks like I have to drive.
Oh, no, I have to drive!
What do you mean breaks?
What are breaks?
Oh, wait.
Hold down A to boost.
Oh, cool!
Wow!
Oh, whoa.
Oh, shoot.
Uh, I need to go this way, I think.
Oh.
Wait, hold on.
Uh, hold on.
One second.
Oh.
What the hell?
Why is there so much stuff in the road?
Uh, this way?
Am I doing this right?
Oh, shoot.
This is definitely tough.
This is tricky.
Oh, we're here!
Uh, where?
Where was Barry?
Uh...
Uh, oh, I think I just...
Oh, okay, here it is.
Okay, just kidding.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
Uh.
How do I get around that?
The music stopped.
Uh, do I push it?
Uh-huh.
Now it's just a comedy.
Uh...
Walk, how do I get out?
Wait...
Oh, okay.
What's that?
Where?
No, please let me drive through!
Uh...
Oh.
Okay, we're fine.
Never mind.
I think I might have missed a bunch of stuff.
Because I...
The flare gun was probably the best weapon I could imagine
against the dark things I was facing.
Yeah, that's so true.
Um...
Anyway.
What were they saying?
I don't remember.
Ah!
Wait, what happened to...
Ouch!
My flare gun!
Hey!
I'm missed with the flare.
Wait, that's embarrassing.
Oh my gosh.
Ah!
Oh my god, wait, you're right there.
Okay.
Oh, okay, okay.
I couldn't remember how the flare gun worked again.
Alright, um, any more of those?
Is this gonna go out again?
My safety light?
Uh, where?
Okay, we just...
Oh, Barry?
was the kidnapper oh just kidding you son of a bitch where's
my wife enough horse where is she you deliver the manuscript
and you can have your woman back as simple as that I don't
listen listen I'm gonna need time to finish it I still need
to write the ending a week a week not done I need a week two
days the old bright falls coal mine is nearby you can find
it easy city boy the main building there at noon.
You bring the manuscript.
You'll get your wife.
If not, well, get me.
Yes, yes, I get you.
Uh-oh.
All these demon birds.
Why is it every time I go home?
There's demon birds waiting for me.
Can I kill these guys?
From here?
Excuse me.
You're not demon, are you?
Demonic birds?
You're gonna attack me or...
What are we doing here?
They're like sky ants.
Barry had talked about birds over the phone.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm working on it.
The lights!
Barry!
Why did the lights go out?
Uh...
Are they gone?
They seem gone.
Uh...
The darkness controls the taken.
Yes.
Thank you.
Wait, why is it?
Wait, what is that?
Oh.
Yes, thank you.
Is there anything else in here?
I think I got everything from before, but...
The door?
Controls him.
Okay, in there, babe.
Where?
Why did the lights go out?
Oh.
Oh boy.
What's happening?
Oh!
Oh boy.
What's happening?
Oh boy Wow!
Ammo!
Batters.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh my god.
Yeah, a little bit.
Can I get in?
Will you let me in?
Wait, what's this?
More flares!
Oh, shoot.
Oh, my God!
Crazy!
Can I commit?
Can you let me in?
No?
Oh.
What's going on here?
Oh!
Defeat the birds!
Oh, fun!
Oh.
Okay.
Good thing I didn't show you.
shoot that.
We're getting there.
Oh no.
Ah, shoot.
We're killing them.
A little by little.
This is so funny.
Am I getting them?
Yeah.
One by one.
How many do I need to take out?
I'm working on it.
Where are they?
Are they on the other side?
Oh no, here they are.
Yeah, you stupid birds.
Where are they?
Oh.
Yeah.
I got them that good a good amount, I think.
Oh.
They're a little more aggressive now.
How many birds do I need to take out?
Pick that up.
Yes.
Oh, that was a good amount.
Oh my god, my eyes.
So bright.
Oh, they really are gone.
Hey, Al.
I'm sorry for thinking you were having a second.
Yeah, you should be.
I sent Barry to the town to ask around about a man fitting
the kidnapper's description.
He'd go through the archives of local paper.
Perhaps he could learn something.
Anything about the island and the cabin that had
disappeared.
The man wanted a manuscript.
I had to try to write him one to get Alice back.
This one was a long episode.
It wasn't so long, I feel.
For me, the supernatural had always been nothing but a
metaphor for the human psyche.
I'm assuming I'm at the end of the episode.
A tool to use in writing fiction.
Now, it was happening for real.
And I couldn't put a single word on paper.
No.
Not the writer's block.
Barry Wheeler speaking.
Yeah, Barry was being reasonable.
I found Mr. Wake's pages.
Oh, you sweet, brilliant girl.
Could you and Mr. Wake come back?
She sounds drunk or something.
We'll be there in less than an hour.
See you soon.
Bye now.
Have a great day.
Hope you come back soon.
Welcome to the oh dear diner.
Good girl.
Ooh, creepy.
Ba-da-ba-ba.
This is, this is very like, this feels, this song feels very
Silent Hill.
Woo!
Is this gonna get me DMCA though?
End of- Holy cow!
It's okay, the last episode got, uh, what's the word?
Oh, the song is so good, though.
I'll just turn it down a little bit.
The last episode got, or the last stream got, uh, got,
what's it called?
Gotcha, too.
So, yay!
Oh.
On Alan Wake, Alice has been kidnapped.
Alan, please help me.
You'll do exactly what I say if you ever want to hear your
wife again.
I can't tell anyone except my agent Barry.
Damn it, Barry, the killer.
You're my best friend, and I'm worried that you're not right
in the head.
Wait, what about the dog?
The ranch was a manuscript I supposedly wrote that's coming
true before my eyes.
happened just the way it was on that page they got rusty
what about the dog only a few scattered pages i want the
entire manuscript the deadline is in two days i found mr
wake's pages good i found mr wake's pages episode three
ransom how the hell did she get her hands on the manuscript
yeah he could have run away i don't know we'll watch this
before uh i told you you were too hard on her before i end
listen i found out all sorts of interesting stuff while i
was digging around yeah Mr. Wake, it's Sheriff Breaker.
Oh, no.
We have an FBI agent here.
Agent Nightgown.
Oh, no!
FBI.
He is anxious to see you.
You'd better come to the station.
Okay, I'll be right over, Sheriff.
I think I'm in trouble.
Let's make this quick, huh?
The dog corpse was right outside the hole in the wall.
No, it wasn't.
I didn't see it.
Oh.
I'm the manager.
We're looking for Rose.
Works as a waitress down at the diner.
Rose, sure.
Nice girl.
Who wants to know?
I'm Alan White.
wake the writer huh oh he knows you were visiting well i'll
show you her trailer that rose she's a nice girl why are you
looking at me like that as i was saying ow i found all sorts
of weird stuff from the local newspaper's archives how long
is this episode you guys is it long this place is crazy
disappearances mysterious deaths urban legends come true and
get this most of this stuff takes place around the same as
the other one okay well you ain't wrong we'll we'll we'll do
it next one then three and four longer really okay okay okay
then we'll we'll save it for next time since i will be on
doki stream in a bit uh in two hours so dang it each episode
is like two hours unless you run through it i was a little
slow on this one that stinking that stinking lover's the
flares really got me good but cool then we got through I'm
going to rename these as like the episode names so this was
episode 2 and then we did episode 1 last time oh man I'm
glad though that I remember the gameplay at first kind of
stumped me but I'm getting used to it I'm getting used to
that combat so it's like MGS 4 it is lover's peak was a sham
all i was just there was some guy that kidnapped my wife
what a scam try princess thank you so much for the gift for
the dodo thank you i just almost said gifted thank you thank
you wait we have some time though we can chit chat for a bit
if you guys want let's chit chat for i'll chit chat for like
a little while before i go get dinner for before
before uh oh doki stream wait hold on i'll be right back
wait one second one second one second let me set you guys up
wait uh one second as well
um one second there we go
Hello!
I came from underneath the table.
Alan Wake is one of my favorite franchises, which makes it
even better that you're playing it on my birthday!
Vampire!
Happy birthday!
Let me quit the game.
Quit the menu.
Okay.
Oh, one thing that I like about the game that's fun is each
episode here.
Hold on.
other screen oh where are you wait oh oh there it is the
each episode does the title screen changes i always think
that's fine okay anyway quit the game quit oh no i just
clicked continue game no please no wait quick quit to menu
quit quit i'm quitting i'm quitting yeah i love when title
so fun this game is very scary but my girlfriends really
like it so i wanted to watch someone play it for a while and
watching you play it is a real treat oh my god death pigeon
it is spooky but it's actually not so bad i feel let me put
on some music i was very excited to see you'd be joining
doki again of course of course nexi any other friends you'll
do an mgs backseat for a roach in the whole series back on
metal gear i think she i think matara khan needs to get back
on metal gear let's see
hold on
that was my controller that roach will she remember anything
correctly probably i think she'll have to replay what did
she she played one and two she didn't play three solid chaos
for welcome back thank you thank you thank you
Nimmy, Nimmy too.
Hi, Ghost Rider.
She did try an MGS week before.
Did she?
Wait, she starred in three.
But didn't finish.
How far did she get in three?
Oh, mama.
I wonder if Nimmy would like Metal Gear.
But now that Delta's out, I feel like that's a good way to
play three, honestly.
I mean, you could do either, but if you're wanting like a,
you know, a newer experience.
Though, I mean, like the original holds up so well, so it's
fine to play either, honestly.
Nimmy would try to play three as a vegan.
Oh, you're right!
You're right!
Oh no!
I guess you could, right?
Probably.
Oh my gosh, you guys know I just noticed.
My Opie mouse pad has a stain on it.
I don't know if this is a stain.
Oh no, I'm gonna have to wash it.
Nimmy is pretty good at Hitman.
Hitman.
It's like a Pikmin, but a Hitman.
You think she'd take to it?
I think really, I mean, obviously I love...
Well, you know, I'm not so good at the gameplay, but I still
have fun with it.
But the story is really...
What gets me so much about the game, so...
It's not just playing it.
Hitman.
Pikmin-Hipman.
I want to play Pikmin.
I want to play Pikmin, but I hear it's hard.
I hear it's, like, actually, like, a tricky...
the tough game, at least the earlier ones.
It is, it can be.
Yeah.
I'm an MGS story enjoyer, not a stealth gamer.
Yeah, exactly, exactly.
Pickerman, it can be tricky.
It's stressful.
All my little guys are gonna, I grow attached to my guys.
I don't want them to die.
I think I'll cry.
That rhymes.
My guys!
I don't want them to...
I love my guy.
I don't want him to die.
I will cry.
All right.
Reese, what are you trying to do there?
What are you trying to do?
You'll experience mass extinction events.
That might make me so sad.
Active time management game.
Ha.
I don't know if I would be good at it.
it.
I'll try it one day maybe.
See if I like it.
I couldn't handle the Pikmin crying as their soul slips.
So I spent the whole month or the whole time.
Wait, I spent the whole time boxing monsters Mano Mano in
Pikmin too.
They're cute but expendable.
There's like a that Pokemon Go, but it's Pikmin, right?
They don't die in that, right?
Do they at least live a happy life then?
Do they grow old together?
Do they have a family?
Surely they do.
Surely.
They all go to the farm upstate.
It's more of a walking game.
Wasn't that Pokemon Go also?
I never played Pokemon Go.
because when I finally so I was in Japan when Pokemon go
came out and and it was not available I guess it wasn't
available in Japan it was available in overseas first and so
all my friends were doing it all my friends were playing
Pokemon Go and I was like oh man that looks so fun all my
friends are going out and and everything and then i came
back home and and the craze was over nobody was playing
pokemon go anymore and so i never got to do it let me see it
let me see it when did okay let's see it pokemon go pokemon
go release in the u.s australia july 6 2016 Japan was July
22nd, 2016.
But I came back later.
Actually, I didn't know that about Japan.
That it was released July 22nd.
It was within the same month.
But I came back later.
So, wow, it's been a whole decade since Pokemon Go.
Wow.
Actually, maybe I downloaded it.
it but there was nothing in japan yet i don't remember i
don't remember i'm glad you're enjoying this game speaking
of old nintendo games i bet you'd have fun with the
warioware games oh yes wait there was that one warriorware
game i think it came out for uh the switch i wanted to do it
in 3d oh warriorware oh what was it it was like the one move
it I wanted to do in 3D.
Wait, maybe we could do that sometime soon.
That'd be so fun.
My 3D is still pretty scuffed though.
My home setup at least.
Is it fine?
Did anyone play it?
Move It is so good.
You're actually moving it, right?
I like to move it, move it.
Wait, what is get it together?
Oh, there's a new one!
Wait, it says...
Wait, no.
Sorry.
Demo available.
Which one?
Is this one newer?
I have played WarioWare games before, though.
Get it together as older.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
WarioWare, move it.
Oh, I'm looking at it now.
Let me put it down on my calendar so I remember.
That would be so fun.
Let's see.
Maybe not next week, but I could do the week after.
I'll put it on.
Warrior wear.
Warrior wear move.
Nice.
Next week, I think I'm already off.
all busy i mean i'm already i'm doing like two games you
know like i'm working on working through alan wake and then
i have dispatch so that kind of already takes up a little
bit of time thank you for being so cute
no warrior where warrior doko still waiting on deadly
premonition maybe after well i feel like deadly premonition
is I don't want to say similar to Alan Wake, but you know
what I mean?
Maybe after Alan Wake.
There's a game in between Alan Wake and Alan Wake 2 I have
to play, isn't there?
Uh, what was it?
Control.
It's actually pretty similar.
Okay, that's what I thought, right?
They're both love letters to Twin Peaks.
We're in our funky Twilight Zone Twin Peak.
Silly era.
Not plot length, just the same universe.
Do I have to play it in between then?
A lot of people were saying I should.
Maybe in release, control came out before Alan Wake 2, I'm
guessing.
There is some connection.
high i think it's good progression for the references very
much recommended but not necessary is what it seems okay
okay i think wait let me see how long to beat long to beat
control oh okay it's just a couple like maybe two three
streams that's not so bad i saw the clip about that chat's
child support can you send it to me soon mint junior needs a
new maid outfit Oh no, look at the time!
You could cut it if you want to rush Alan Wake.
I'm not necessarily trying to rush it.
It's just also...
I need to play through more Ace Combat before Ace Combat 8
comes out.
Too many games!
It's too...
Like, I want to do that.
I still have...
I have like a list of games.
Like I have on here.
I had even mass effect on here, but it's so long.
I don't know if I'll do it.
I have near.
I have uncharted.
I have quite a bit.
Steak too juicy.
Exactly.
Takizo!
Thank you for the fun, Keto.
Thank you!
Pretty sure Control has an Alan Wake DLC.
Oh!
Also, welcome back, Kiyoki.
Running away from child support like Virgil.
How disappointing.
Where's your child's abhor?
He never says that.
He is never.
Near, far.
Have you ever listened to that song?
And then she says, I believe that the heart does.
You know, she says the heart does, but it kind of sounds
like hot dog.
I believe that the hot dog goes on.
Kinda sounds like a hot dog.
Because she kind of says heart like hot.
Heart.
And then dog.
She doesn't really announce her at the, oohs.
Oohs.
Hot dog.
Thanks for the hot dogs.
I'm black now, I've only seen you wide.
This is my goth mode.
How do you feel?
Do we like goth, minky?
Well, it's less... It is like a dark mode.
Let's goth, maybe.
I don't know.
See you on DocuStream, yeah!
See you there!
Hot dog, hot dog, hot dog, hot dog, hot dog, hot dog.
I kind of want a burger today.
I kind of want...
Five guys.
It's different.
Purple Minto coming back?
I mean, I could always...
It's weird.
Whoa!
I glitched!
I glitched for real!
That was freaky.
Never mind.
It doesn't work.
Sorry.
It died my bangs.
You're telling me it took five guys to make this burger?
What is your favorite burger joint?
My favorite burger joint is actually a local place.
So I can't say because it's not a chain.
It's like a little tiny place that I really like that.
I'm like, Kappa, Kappa, Kappa.
Why is your hot dog a three?
Wait, why is your sparkly?
What did you put in it?
What a burger?
Oh, yeah, what a burger.
My favorite is local two.
Foster Freeze
Local place Fudruckers What a name I like in and out But the
fries suck Okay wait a second I like in and out too And I
always thought the fries were like styrofoam But I think Oh
I love Culver's Yeah I love Culver's But I think I've become
like kind of...
What's the word?
I think I've become like...
Homestuck?
No.
Uh...
Homestuck.
No, not homestuck.
Uh...
I've become homestucked?
What's the word?
What is it?
Stuck?
home stuck home oh my god stockholm syndrome into liking the
fries of in and out now i really love you know home stuck
stuck home is home
stuck syndrome poor spirit trapped at home i mean that's
like a lot of ghosts though god the mean loves five guys she
also likes the fast food places hey hey hey
hi man i'm ocelot again in like two hours do you have any
requests for the cosplayer named evan k covers
wait that reminds me phoebe sent me a video of her dressed
as ocelot and she was like 12 shots and i'm like who made
you do this
I've never even read Homestuck, but it's like getting an
anime, isn't it, apparently?
Amphetamine!
Thank you so much for the pig!
Burger funds for dark mode, Minky.
Also, sorry to be a bother, but can I please get out?
This is not a bother at all!
Happy!
Stockholm Syndrome, like the city in Sweden.
Sorry.
I don't know what's wrong with my brain.
Hot take.
I love AMC popcorn, but only when it's stale.
Not a fan for fresh popcorn.
That's not hot take.
Actually, though, I love movie theater popcorn when it's
fresh.
No, I love movie theater popcorn when it's soggy with
butter.
For the record, let the record show Minto is homestuck for
fries.
I love movie theater popcorn when it's soggy with butter.
Oh, so good.
What am I doing?
Evan!
Evan, you terrible and wonderful creature the way that you
are.
Thank you.
Nothing's wrong with your brain.
There's something a little wrong with my brain, maybe.
You disgust me.
Good.
I want you to think that I'm terrible.
Think I'm terrible.
And also get worse.
oh i don't know why all my super chats are my third super
chat and shiny it's been like this for years but that one's
normal breathe it's your it's your birthday it's your third
birthday couple you're three years old get worse get worse
oh butter saga movie popcorn is good yeah i hadn't been to
the movies in a long time until I went and saw the recent
Wicked and then I got I got a movie popcorn and I was like
can I get some butter on that and they were like oh yeah it
was great
mmm butter do you guys have you guys ever had butter in your
ramen before like you get a miso ramen and you get corn and
you get butter in there yeah baby it's so good it's so good
it's a my ocesome my recommendation
whatever is wrong with me and dough is right for me I love
the way and minto's brain works except when it's being mean
to her or Metsch's Homestuck.
Was Homestuck any good, though?
Like, now that we can reflect on it, was it actually good
and we just didn't like, and just the fandom was kind of
cringe?
Or was it, like, I don't know, I've never read it or
anything.
Careful.
It was all right.
It was unique.
Like, you...
I think we talked about this before.
You had to, like, you have to have read it with the flash,
right?
Or something?
Never burden anyone with knowing about Homestuck or
Vivzipop.
It's a burden.
This knowledge, I have to carry it with me every day.
For the rest of my afterlife, I have to carry this knowledge
of Homestuck and Vivzipop.
I remember one time I was at an anime convention and it was
like maybe one, two in the morning.
It was quite late and I was walking with my friends and I
quite remember very vividly seeing a circle of homestuck
cosplayers.
They were like, and you knew they were homestucks because
they were gray.
They had like the gray paint on them, the body paint.
And they were surrounding a guy who was passed out drunk on
the floor.
And my first thought was, oh no!
Homestuck cosplayers!
Then my second thought was, oh no!
I hope that guy is okay!
And I sure hope that they called for help!
That's a guy that's passed out drunk On the floor
Circling him like vultures They were like singing They were
like holding hands And like singing something around this
guy Like they were doing a ritual to him I hope that guy's
okay today If you ever do the thing I recommend with the
Orville oil.
It has an ANC bag of popcorn.
Be a bit careful.
You don't need as much of the Orville oil as the theater
stuff.
Thank you, Dargo.
I remember you mentioning that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Back in my day, I went to an anime convention.
I got smacked with a yaoi paddle and got glomped.
Good times.
I'm gonna glompe you.
Valid order of emergencies.
They definitely sacrificed that, dude.
Oh.
Like, those two girls those girls that tried to sacrifice
that girl that other girl for slender man like that's a real
that's a real like uh what's the word a real crime didn't
she escape yeah she was hardcore they like they they like
thought they killed her and she crawled back to like get
help it's actually so messed up she survived it's amazing
she was so hardcore yeah they stabbed her a ton and now the
girls i think they're like still in custody or something
it's really badass that she survived like so cool that she
not cool that she got stabbed obviously but like so cool
that her like will to live was so strong like oh my god it
was a quite a long time ago.
No, the girl didn't die.
She lived.
One tried to escape recently!
That's scary.
Do you think they probably don't believe in Slender Man
anymore, right?
I hope.
Scary.
Was that a real story?
It was, it was, yeah.
Did she have a lightning bolt-shaped scar?
The girl who lived.
It burns every time she thinks of Slender Man.
Oh.
That's pretty freaky, though.
Ah.
Slender Man.
Collect my pages.
He said collect the pages.
He didn't say murder a person.
Come on!
Get the lore right!
Come on, guys!
Spread my pages!
Spread my code!
Oh, I want to go on the Tron ride again.
It was pretty fun.
Even though it was so short.
What is his lore?
He's just a long guy.
I don't know.
I think he like kidnaps Children or something too?
But there was like always that.
I always think of that one.
Like one of the first photos of him that emerged was like
the one of him like in the playground or whatever.
Right?
Something?
I don't know.
I feel like the lore is all messed up.
There was never like an established lore or something,
right?
Because where does he get his suits?
Who's his tailor?
He does it himself.
Marble Hornets is the only lore I remember.
Yeah, something.
I mean, I know it was like the Photoshop of him happened,
and then there was like the creepypastas made from him.
He's supposed to appear in urban environments too, so it
always bothered me that the popular game was based in the
woods.
Um, actually, my Slender Man would appear in the city.
Actually, Slender Man is in Tokyo right now.
Imagine.
Oh my gosh, wait.
That'd be a great idea for what's it called?
Chilla's art.
They can make their own slender set in Japan.
Slender, the eight pages, bring it back.
Bring it back.
I wonder how like, not fun, but I bet playing that game
nowadays is like pretty iconic.
It's like, wow, this is where, like, page collection games
started, you know?
He was in the woods for glamping.
He probably had a really nice, like, what do you say?
Like, uh, like, uh, um...
He probably was going to do, like, a nice engagement or
something.
He had his suit on.
He was ready.
nobody showed up and he's really sad the tall lady oh what's
her name Hachi Shaku Sama or whatever what's her name Hachi
Hachi Shaku Sama yeah I was right her and Slenderman are
were were to be engaged and he had a suit on to propose and
she rejected him and now he's really sad.
That's the lore.
Dimidom.
Wait, how do you say her name?
Dim.
Demitrescu.
The U is silent.
Demetresk Demetresk Demetresk Owner of the Dimdale The
Dimsdale Demetresk Dome Yeah The mattress No The bed Okay
Demetresk That's right Yippee I want to play Resident Evil.
Oh, another game.
There's too many games.
You guys.
Oh, my God.
I just Googled Hachishaku-sama.
I was looking at images of her.
Look.
Look what I just saw.
This.
This is on Wattpad.
No stinking way.
Nothing is an original thought.
them it's slender man and hachi shaku sama they're already
shipped a tall tale of romance chapter one slender who hachi
shaku sama's plv i was walking deep into a forest with a
young child holding my left hand she looked at me where are
we going hachi shaku sama she asked i looked down at her a
small shadow forming on my face because of my white straw
hat I smiled.
A wonderful place where anything and everything exists.
You can do whatever you want.
Wait, when do they meet?
Oh, here, here, here.
Oh, my God.
I stopped in the middle of a clearing.
Where are we, Hachi?
I stay silent as a static noise begins to echo through the
woods.
I've never heard this noise before.
When am I gonna get to go?
Silence, I demanded in my deep voice, which was deeper than
a fully grown male.
Who wrote...
Is this supposed to be...
I can't tell if this is supposed to be serious or not.
The static continued.
My eyes darted around, my head not moving.
Hachi, the young girl, asked.
I looked down to see her tilting her head as someone in
front of us.
I look up.
I see a pale white man.
He has no face and is wearing a suit.
He seemed to be a few inches taller than me, but I didn't
think much of it.
I raised an eyebrow.
He seemed to be coming closer and closer.
I stand there, the girl trembling in my hand.
but then she stops I look back down at the girl to see her
giggling she looks up at me is this your husband Hachi how
many chapters is this this chapter 1 how many chapters next
part chapter 2 chapter 3 chapter 4 wait hold on maybe if I
on their their wet pad how many chapters is it oh it's only
four chapters how disappointing I thought this was going to
be like you know like their die-hard ship you know what I
mean I didn't know I wanted Minto fanfic audio readings it
It needs to be a manua or something.
The magic number.
Wait, you're right.
That is a spooky number now, isn't it?
But it should be 44, at least.
I wonder how it ends.
Hold on.
Wait, chapter 4 is meeting Slender Man.
What?
That doesn't make much sense.
He sighs.
They refer to me as Slender Man.
Though the creepypastas call me other things.
Which I will not say, for they are true.
truly ridiculous.
Minto audiobook, please, please, please.
If somebody, I feel like I probably couldn't do that because
of copyright.
I don't like the, I don't like how meta this is.
They call me, they call me Slenderman.
If you are tired of too many games, you should read some fix
on stream and be peak.
Maybe.
Yeah!
Slender Man breeds his own creepy pastas.
That's so cringe.
That means Slender Man is like Googling himself.
That's so... Oh my gosh.
What is it called when you like search yourself or whatever?
That's so cringe.
Forgot to mention I sent some videos of Gumbas.
Oh yeah!
I saw them cover!
I saw the Gumbas.
I love his eyes.
Yeah, ego-searching, ego-searching!
He's ego-searching himself.
That's cringe.
Oh my god.
Come on, come on.
Slenderman.
He's like, I wonder what fanfics are about me today.
I can't search myself.
If you search Mint, obviously, like, my name is, like, you
know, not only just a color, but also, uh a crypto so the so
all i get if i were to search mint is like oh yeah this is
uh a minted uh something something coin about uh about uh
this is this is this is duck coin minted today Sacred and
terrible air The book Disco Elysium is based on Would be a
good read on stream Oh my goodness Reading though I don't
mind it It's like doing a visual novel Might be kind of
tough Take a long time too Because all I, you know If I read
and also comment Takes a long time I thought of the plant Oh
yeah The plant too Yeah yeah yeah Yeah And then there's also
Mint Mobile, the cell phone service, so it's impossible for
me, which is fine.
I'm not gonna, I don't, you know, probably better for my,
for my mental.
Bye, bye, boy, boy.
Someone out there's a real auntie.
They're just like, I hope she sees this when ego searching.
I don't see anything.
to search yourself are there don't tell me i don't need to
know sometimes i get curious but i'm like i can't i
literally can't so i i don't i don't see anything i i i
literally can't do it
here's your last name are they calling me first name last
name that makes me feel like i'm trouble by like my mom no
please please i'm i'm a good ghost linux mint you have so
many styles yeah my name is not very seo friendly that's
okay though preserve your mental health don't ego search i
don't i don't
ego searching is unhealthy don't i instead search I search
for clothes on Mercari.
That's what I've been doing a lot recently.
Garlemald!
Welcome back!
Hey.
Where's your message?
I totally watch Minto's fanfic reading Rainbow.
Maybe I could do like a thing where you guys send me in some
fanfic to read and I will read it.
to like screen it first but then i could read it blind i
thought you'd search up koharu oh yeah i have a danbor link
always open with koharu yeah i'm looking at koharu all the
time not my immortal actually i've never read my immortal
i've only know that it's infamous make steiner read them
when the middle name is invoked as well run scary i've
never read it well guys i'm starting to get hungry so i
think i'm gonna go get my burger and then i think i'm gonna
get ready to hang out with doki and watch metal gear maybe
she'll actually play the game this time go consume i i think
you guys should as well consume and enjoy wrapped up a
stream she leaned back took a breath and stretched the game
had hard parts but she slayed like always and made her
eyeballs proud with all tension relieved by yaps she felt
much better and had a wonderful and restful night thank you
uh duargo wake alan go oh my gosh wait like a like Instead,
it's Alan Go.
She might play MGS or Fortnite.
We'll see.
She better not play Fortnite.
Go eat.
I sent one more Gumbush video just now that you should
watch.
Can we watch together?
Oh, I see it.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
It's not one that I can download.
I'll watch it.
I'm going to say we could watch it together on stream.
but
have you talked to Maddie about playing the remedy games she
can help you figure out what to play or not oh that's a good
idea actually I haven't talked to Maddie in a bit so it
would be good to reach out that's a great idea thank you to
all find some calorie mate for stream wait I have some
actually 19 months Andrew thank you wait keys in the eye
they added today I'm gonna messenger right now we are
playing metal gear right i'm gonna be like where where dokyo
we are playing metal gear tonight right right right right
right happy new year me to my oh she matches her oh my gosh
it's been a while hope you're doing good today you too she
said yeah okay in like an hour and a
you might play fortnight she said she confirmed oh she
doesn't be she doesn't release until next week okay it's
because every time there's a new skin that I like well who
does she who does she like I ever play mogul right cracks
and I log on to Fortnite and buy it.
You could get the Metal Gear skins when they come back
again.
Okay.
I'm gonna go eat.
I'm starting to get so hungry and I'm ready for Borgor.
So thank you guys.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh, South Park just released kids.
Oh geez.
Oh, I see, I see.
Thank you, everyone.
Thank you so much.
Oh, tomato.
I will see you guys when I see you later, which hopefully
will be our doki stream.
Wait, can I read her?
Let's see if she has a thing up.
Oh, there she does.
Okay, we'll read into that.
Thank you, everyone!
Bye-bye!
Otomito!
Oh, my tummy is growling.
Bye-bye!